Live auf dem 32. Chaos-Communication-Kongress. Hallo, willkommen. Wie ist denn die Getränkesituation eigentlich hier?
Gibst du mir mal den Rum? Ja, wir haben... Ja, kannst du mir noch den Rum geben?
Ach so, du meinst ich trinke die ganze Zeit Chunk?
Ohne...
Gibt's eigentlich noch diese Grashotline dieses Jahr?
Gibst du mir mal den Rum?
Wir haben nämlich alle schon einen im Tee.
Und wieder in mein Getränk voll.
Konfetti Mexicana.
Runter das Zeug.
Geil, ich stehe ja total drauf, so was.
Also früher war mehr Gras.
Wenn man Hamburg auf ein Getränk reduzieren will, dann heißt das Mexicana.
Das ist auch die einzige Art von Tomatensaft, die man auf der Erde trinkt, ne?
Ich bin schon lange keine Post mehr gekommen.
Also diese Seidenschrass, das funktioniert wirklich fantastisch.
Außer das Gras.
Ja, außer das Gras.
Normal, die Dinger untereinander nicht abgesichert. Das heißt, du machst dein Cable Modem auf, das geht relativ einfach, da hast du eine Konsole an, da ist ein Linux drauf, machst das Ding erstmal klar, loggst dich dann auf deinem Cable Modem ein und das hängt, wie gesagt, in diesem Management-Laden, die User sind alle voneinander nicht abgestimmt. Und dann tendest du einfach vom einem zum anderen rüber. Oder früher. Das haben sie jetzt abgestellt nach dem, das dem man jetzt reportet hat.
Also, aber ich meine...
Mal ehrlich, ich meine, was...
J-Net ist natürlich auch schwierig.
Was sind denn das für hirnamputierte Leute, die, ich meine, hallo?
Das merken die doch nie, die Kunden. Und dann...
Der übrigens auch, um darauf zurückzukommen, wo du gerade sagst, das ist der mit seiner Motor-Elektronik. Dann merkst du, auch wie dein Hacker, der hat es nämlich auch erst mal auf Ebay so ein scheiß Cable Modem erst mal aufgemacht, bevor er seins befummelt hat. Aber er hat dann gesehen, ja ok, da musst du dann nur das Ding aufschrauben, eine Konsole da anstecken an das Ding und dann kannst du dich erst mal mit ihm unterhalten. Dann hat er sich das aufgemacht. Und dann noch so andere kleine Details, wie zum Beispiel die Dinge, hatten alle dasselbe Passwort.
Und dann so, das musst du aber auch verstehen, es gibt schon seit längerem eine Passwort-Knappheit. Und da ist jetzt nicht mehr für jedes Gerät ein eigenes Passwort.
Na ok, da muss ich kurz sagen, du hast ja das Problem für jedes Gerät ein eigenes Passwort. Die Geräte kommen ja aus einer Fabrik raus und sollen natürlich möglichst alle das gleiche auf ihrem Flash-Ship haben. Also die gleiche Firmware. Das heißt, du musst ja irgendwie auf dem Gerät ein Passwort generieren. Und die übliche Praxis ist, dass du irgendeine chaotische Funktion nimmst, ein paar Hashes über deine Mac-Adresse machst und dann gehen die bösen Haxer hin und reversen die Funktion, die WLAN-Passwort und WLAN-Name und Seriennummer und Root-Passwort aus der Mac-Adresse generieren und dann bist du auch keinen Schritt weiter. Insofern kannst du besser gleiche Passworte lassen.
Das kannst du auch anders machen.
Das wäre jetzt nicht mein Vorschlag gewesen.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle war es sogar so krass. Eigentlich, er wollte das Ding gar nicht aufmachen, sondern er wollte einfach nur an die SIP-Daten ran.
Er wollte an die Daten für Voice-over-IP.
Er wollte an die SIP-Daten ran, weil er möchte gerne ein anderes Endgerät für seine Telefonie benutzen, als Dreckskabelzeug, was Kabel-Deutschland daraus tut. Oder ein Phone mittlerweile. Dann hat er angerufen, ich hätte gerne die SIP-Daten und die so gibt es nicht. Dann hat er noch ein paar Mal mit denen hin und her diskutiert und die so nö. Er hat sie auch gefragt, was ist denn ein anderes Gerät dran? Da hängen sie auch darüber, welches Gerät sie haben, aber wir sagen die Zusatzdaten nicht. Dann hat er sich gedacht, fuck it, dann mach ich das Ding mal auf und gucke einfach mal nach, wie die SIP-Daten sind. Und dann hat er sich das angeguckt, wie diese Daten überhaupt provisioniert werden. Das heißt, so ein Kabelmodell, wenn der jungfreulich ist, dann meldet sich das erstmal über so ein Management-Netz bei so einem Zentralserver und sagt so, hey, ich bin Seriennummer, schieß mich tot, Make-Adresse, tralala, gib mir mal Konfigurationsdaten. So, und dann hat er sehen, okay, da krieg ich das Ding da drüber. Dann hat er diese Request von Hand gemacht und dann hat er festgestellt, ja, kann den selben provisionierten Server fragen, gibt mir auch die Daten, ist ja schick. Und dann hat er sich irgendwie mal ein bisschen geirrt oder hat er irgendwie zwischen einer anderen IP-Adresse gekriegt oder was, jedenfalls hat er diesen provisionierten Server wieder mal gefragt, hat plötzlich Daten für einen anderen Kunden gekriegt mit Username, Passwort und tralala drin. Dann hat er sich gedacht, Moment mal, was steht denn eigentlich noch alles drin? Und da stehen dann halt eben noch so alle möglichen anderen Zugänge und Passwörter und tralala drin. Und du konntest eben diesen provisionierten Server nach Daten für alle möglichen Kunden draußen fragen, für alle Kunden, kreuz und quer. Und damit hast du, wie gesagt, sowohl die SIP-Daten gehabt, das kann man ja echt Geld draus machen, das ist ja der Klassiker, deswegen wird ja von außen auch gerne im Internet diese SIP-Zeugs gehackt, damit man denn 900er-Nummern oder internationale Rufnummern anrufen kann, die dann, oder heißt, da kann man sozusagen einen Hack für die russische Mafia aufbereiten, dass die da Geld draus generieren. Also Hack-Feil-Geld. Und hat er aber nicht gemacht, sondern er hat sich das einfach nur angeguckt und hat dann den Leuten auch Bescheid gesagt. Und dann hat er gesagt, das war ein bisschen insecure, was er da macht, und dann haben sie irgendwie Tellnet zu und SSH aufgemacht, aber immer noch auf dieselbe Art und Weise Passwörter vergeben oder so was. Und dann hat er dann nochmal angerufen und gesagt, das ist aber immer noch braun. Und jetzt haben sie das inzwischen so gemacht, dass du jetzt nur noch deine eigenen Provisionierungsdaten abrufen kannst und noch so ein paar andere Sachen reinmachst. Und er war schlau, er hat die nicht direkt angerufen, weil er hat schon geahnt, dass er dann sofort irgendwie dräufzig Anwälte vor der Tür hat und ein SEK, was durchs Fenster springt, sondern er hat das, glaube ich, über Heise oder so was, hat einmal die Presse dazwischen geschaltet, was auch sehr schlau ist, weil die können nämlich diese Sachen weiterleiten und fragen, ohne dass sie gleich angepumpt wären dafür. Also es ist ein schöner Vortrag.
Er hat vor allem auch sehr schön vorgetragen, so einen schönen roten Faden drin, wo das Problem dann immer größer wird, wenn man anfängt so, es geht los mit dem...
Eine Tür aufgemacht, ohne dass sich noch mehr Türen dahinter.
Das ist sehr schön vorgetragen worden, ja.
Gut, habe ich noch nicht gesehen, werde ich nachholen.
Wollen wir alle durchgehen?
Nö, will ich nicht. Wir haben jetzt hier so eine kleine Auswahl und ich könnte nur was zu Sachen sagen, die ich gesehen habe.
Also auf jeden Fall Fun Talk von meiner Seite 2. Ich bin ja immer für die lustigen Sachen. 20 Oscillators in 20 Minutes fand ich auch echt sympathisch. Den Vortrag war schwer unter Stress, glaube ich. Da wehrte es vor. Also gerade am Anfang. Und irgendwie die Menge ist auch noch nicht so direkt darauf eingestiegen. Aber im Verlauf des Vortrags wurde es dann durchaus gut. Und ich glaube, die Soundanlage hat auch mal einen deutlichen Funktionstester erfahren. Wo ging es denn nach? Na ja, da wurden halt so live quasi vor Publikum so Oszillatoren halt aneinandergesteckt und mal auf die Soundanlage gegeben. Und dann gab es da noch eine Geschichte dazu und war einfach so ein Vortrag, wo man so ohne Erwartung reingehen kann und dann irgendwie wieder so total gefnordet einfach rausläuft, so denkt so, ey, diese Veranstaltung. Also den kann man sich auf jeden Fall auch mal geben. Und dann fand ich natürlich auch noch gut hier diese geheimagenten Ausstiegsaktionen. Weil ich dachte am Anfang natürlich, okay, das ist jetzt, also ich habe die Beschreibung gelesen und dachte mir, aber nur so mit einem Auge und dachte mir, ah, die haben das wirklich alles gemacht, ne? Also hier mit Flugblättern, Per Drohne über dem, was weiß ich, NSA-Gebäude abwerfen und so weiter. Und dann stellte sich heraus, wenn man genau hinguckt, ach nee, das war jetzt sozusagen so Konzept eher. Was dann aber wiederum doch auch Auswirkungen auf die Realität hatte.
Also sie haben das ja schon gemacht.
Jaja, aber es startete ja nicht so unbedingt als wirklich ernstes Plan, ne? Aber wie sich das dann so entwickelt hat, fand ich auch auf jeden Fall ganz putzig und interessant und witzig und cool. Also war auch so ein Vortrag, ja, ich weiß nicht, alle diese Vorträge, das ist ja auch so eigentlich das Tolle beim Kongress. Selbst wenn man mal gerade so einen Sideslot hat, wo man denkt, ja irgendwie interessiert mich jetzt gerade eigentlich nicht so richtig davon, dann nimmt man sich einfach den, wo man irgendwie nur ein Funkeninteresse hat, setzt sich mal rein. Das kann auch mal eine Niete sein, aber auch ganz oft ist es so, dass man dann rausgeht und sich einglücklich in diesen Talk reingegangen. Der war auf jeden Fall auch gut. Intel Exit hieß ja da wie?
Ja, Intel Exit heißt das Programm ja vom Peng-Kollektiv gestartet. Ja, das war auch sehr schön. Die Unsicherheit von app-basierten Tant-Verfahren im Online-Banking.
Den wollte ich noch gucken.
Das ist auch da so sehr schön. Irgendwann hat man sich gedacht, das wäre ja cool, so zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung machen wir mal. Und dann machen wir irgendwie was, was man weiß und was man hat. Dann kam RSA und hat diese Tokens gemacht und so und war alles cool. Also Tokensystem funktioniert so, du hast einen Schlüsselanhänger, da steht eher RSA drauf und der zeigt irgendwie alle halbe Minute oder jede Minute eine andere Zahlenkombination an. Die generiert er aus einem Geheimnis, was er in sich gespeichert hat, was auf so einer Art Smartcard ist, was man da nicht einfach rauskriegt. Und so ist dieser Token quasi nicht kopierbar. Das ist eigentlich die entscheidende Eigenschaft eines Besitzfaktors in einem Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungsverfahren. Und jetzt ist aber alles natürlich modern so und das muss alles in eine App rein. Und ich glaube, eine der ersten Apps, die das so gibt, ist ja so Google Authenticator.
Das ist nicht eine der ersten, zum Beispiel Blizzard hat irgendwie, glaube ich, noch lange bevor das so im Web, also weil so World of Warcraft ist ja so die große Cashcow und da gab es viel Unfug, der so mit den Accounts getrieben wurde. Und dann haben die relativ zeitig zum Beispiel auch so eine eigene Blizzard-Net irgendwie Two-Factor-Auth-App rausgebracht. War auch irgendwann Pflicht, dass du da über Memo-Registeren irgendwie reinfährst. Und die waren irgendwie schon, also da haben wir im Podcast noch gar nicht über Two-Factor-Auth geschrieben, hatten die das schon irgendwie.
Doch, haben wir. Aber da war es noch nicht cool.
Ah, aber jetzt durch die Sparkassen-App wurde das dann cool?
Das Problem ist, dass die alle wieder glauben, dass sie ihr, dass sie das Rad neu erfinden müssen. Es gibt da super geile Internet-Standards dafür, die unter anderem auch der Google mal wieder implementiert, der Apple natürlich nicht, weil da muss er natürlich wieder selber machen. Und so, ja, aber das könnte man eigentlich auch machen. Dann hätte man auch die Wahl zwischen mehreren Apps und wenn man zum Beispiel so was wie, man Passwort benutzt, man Passwort benutzt auch die Standard-Mechanismen, ja, nennt sich HOTP und TOTP. Und das könnte alles so schön sein.
Könnte alles schön sein, aber gar nicht auf Android, oder? Wo denn?
Gibt X Authenticator. Der Google Authenticator kann alles authentizieren, was TOTP ist. Das wären zum Beispiel auch Dropbox und diverse. Ich kann mal gucken, ich hab so ein Dutzend von...
Aber wie versteckt denn der Google... Also das Problem ist doch, dass du da irgendwie auf einem Betriebssystem läufst, was irgendwie nicht ernst zu nehmen ist. Und dann in Java geschrieben bist, sodass eh jeder irgendwie innerhalb kürzester Zeit die App reversed hat und weiß, wo die ihr Geheimnis herholt.
Die App brauchst du. Der ganze Standard beschreibt, dass alles wieder funktioniert. Das heißt, die App ist vollkommen transparent. Also beim Google Authenticator.
Genau, aber der Angriff, den er jetzt hier, der Vincent Haupert demonstriert hat, war ja hauptsächlich einfach, du bist Ruth auf dem Android, was jetzt wirklich nicht so schwer ist. Und dann hatten sie halt irgendwie eine mangelhafte Ruth-Detection. Und dann hat er halt da irgendwie die Transaktionen manipulieren können, weil sie ja dann auch noch die Sparkassen-Online-Banking-App mit der Sparkassen-App-Tan-App redet. Und du natürlich dann dich dazwischenschalten kannst. Und die Apps dann gegenseitig keine Möglichkeit haben, sich gegenseitig zu authentifizieren.
Ich hab jetzt den Talk nicht gesehen, aber das Problem ist natürlich hier, dass die viel zu verkopfte, aufgeblasene Apps machen, die halt alles Mögliche tun, die vor allem irgendwie hin und her kommunizieren. Bei einer Standard-OTP-App machst du halt nichts anderes als einmal einen QR-Code zu scannen. Damit hast du den Key abgelegt auf deinem Telefon.
Und wo legst du den ab?
Na, den legst du in der App ab.
Genau. Und das ist bei Android doch schon der Anfang allen Übels.
Sicherlich ist das, aber es ist ja auch ein zweiter Faktor. Es ist ja nicht das einzige Passwort, sondern es ist sozusagen das zusätzliche Ding zu dem Passwort.
In dem Fall ja, also konzeptuell ist das einfach in dem Moment, wo du auf dem gleichen Gerät, ja, ich kenne, ja, aber in dem Moment, wo du auf dem gleichen Gerät den Token generierst und das Haben nachweist, wie du das Wissen nachweist über das Kennwort, was du zum Online-Banking hast, hat halt jemand das Konzept nicht verstanden. Das war wahrscheinlich der gleiche, der sich gedacht hat, ja, geil, SMS-TAN.
Also, meiner Meinung nach SMS-TAN und Mobile Banking. Aber Linus hat schon recht, theoretisch ist die Idee, dass du zwei separate Dinge hast. Wenn du das wieder im selben Gerät machst, kannst du sozusagen die Transaktionen überall abfangen und du hast beide Faktoren. Weil du hast den User vor dem Gerät, der dir das Passwort einhackt, und du hast den Two-Factor-Generator, den hast du auch gerade gehackt, und die Transaktion kommt durch das selbe Gerät durch und kannst sie modifizieren.
Du könntest es aber so machen, wie Apple Pay das zum Beispiel macht, dass du halt einfach so ein Secure-Element in deinem Prozessor hast, wo es sozusagen nicht im App-Space ist.
Ja, ohne Frage.
So wie Touch ID funktioniert zum Beispiel. Ja, ich meine, auf Android hast du halt alles Mögliche nicht, da kann man jetzt auch nichts dran ändern, aber trotzdem ist dieses TOTP ein sinnvolles Ding.
Die Anwendungen zählen.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz, ich habe gerade mal geguckt, was ich jetzt alles darüber mache. Ich habe halt auch so irgendeine OTP-App.
Wir reden über eine Sicherheitslücke und Tim gibt jetzt die Liste.
Ich sage ja nur, welche Dienste das überhaupt anbieten. Ich kann das alles mit einer einzigen App abschlachten. Und im Prinzip wäre es ganz sinnvoll für Apple, so eine TOTP-Funktion, direkt in ihr Secure Element mit reinzubauen. Ist jetzt nicht so, aber wäre sinnvoll. Aber Dropbox macht das, Bitstamp macht das.
up.net, wenn es die gab, gibt es noch.
up.net, GitHub macht das.
Mein Bitcoin-Handels.
Das hat sie gebracht.
Drive Database macht das, Tunnel Broker macht das.
Das machen ganz viele, darüber muss man ja nicht sprechen.
Das ist ja auch sehr sinnvoll.
OnCloud macht das. Ich hab ein OnCloud-Plugin für meine OnCloud.
Also die Idee des zweiten Faktors und von mir aus auch eines One-Time-Password-Generators in allen Ehren. Und das ist sicherlich auch die Zukunft, aber eben nicht so, wie wir es da gesehen haben.
Ja, ja, aber das ist, ja, genau, dieses Bild, so, hey, hey, ja, hier, alles klar, so machen wir es jetzt. Ich hab da was gelesen.
Spätestens in dem Moment, wo du irgendwie deine Online-Banking ab an die TAN-Empfangsabdrang knotest, ja, und vollständig da irgendwie zwei APIs machst, die irgendwie über dieses Android miteinander reden, da musst du dir doch irgendwann merken, dass das wahrscheinlich jetzt gar nicht so eine gute Idee war.
Dass du sich gerade aus Convenience-Gründen den zweiten Faktor weg auf die Mietart hättest.
Aber man muss auch sagen, diese Apps haben natürlich ein Problem gelöst. Was du zum Beispiel sehr häufig siehst, ist diese RSA-Tokens in Hardware, die sind teuer, kosten irgendwie 30 Euro so ein Stück oder so, ne? Und wenn du jetzt...
Die übrigens auch dasselbe Protokoll haben.
Jaja, aber man stelle sich jetzt vor, aber die haben eine Secure Storage, da ist der Unterschied. Aber man stelle sich vor, du hättest jetzt irgendwie so eine größere Netzwerkinfrastruktur, ja, wo du auf deine kritischen Geräte Two-Factor Authentication hast, ja. Und dann hast du, man stelle sich jetzt vor, du hättest jetzt diverse Zulieferer und externe Mitarbeiter und Dienstleister, die auch mal auf diese Infrastruktur zugreifen müssen.
Deswegen hat man eine Holzgiste mit einer Kamera drin, wo diese Dinge an der Wand hängen.
Genau, deswegen hast du eine Webcam, die schön die Tokens alle abfilmt und dann kannst du da drauf und dann siehst du immer diese ganzen Tokens. Oder du hast nur den großen Schlüsselbund, und an dem großen Schlüsselbund ist so ein Telefon dran. Und dieser Schlüsselbund mit dem Telefon geht streng reih um. Und den muss dann jeder einen Tag Dienst schieben, und dann klingelt es halt am Telefon, und dann geht man dran und dann sagt die Person am anderen Ende, von welchem Token ist jetzt gerade mal so, die den Inhalt des Displays bräuchte, und dann wird der rausgegeben. Da bist du natürlich mit so einer App, hast du da eigentlich sogar noch ein bisschen bessere Lösungen.
Es gab zum Kongress, da gab es so einen Tweet auch, der rumgeistert oder irgendwie wo genau so eine Webcam mal.
Ich hab übrigens auch schon gesagt, ich hab nämlich bei einem Kunden hier in Berlin vor eineinhalb Jahren so eine Kiste gebaut. Eine schöne Leuchtdiodebeleuchtung drin, dass nicht so viel Strom verbraucht, eine Webcam drin, dann kann man die ganze Kiste irgendwo hin tun. Das ist sozusagen eine Kiste, da geht Strom rein und Internet raus und an der Rückseite der Kiste sind sozusagen die ganzen Dinge mit Velcro aufgeklebt.
Wo wir schon partiell zumindest bei QR-Codes angekommen sind, um mal eine ganz elegante Überleitung zu machen, gab es noch den schönen Talk Q-Artistry, der mich ein bisschen überfordert hat. Ich muss den nochmal gucken.
Ein klassischer Plitz, der überfordert schnell.
Also, Hendrik Plotz hat das gemacht. Der hat sich das mal genauer angeschaut. So, und für den Modus, in dem ich mir den Talk angeschaut habe, reichte meine Konzentration nicht wirklich bis zum Ende. Aber kurz gesagt, das ist sehr schön, hat er mal A, genauer erklärt, wie so ein QR-Code überhaupt aufgebaut ist, der im Übrigen viel komplexer ist, als ich das auch nur...
Als er aussieht?
Als er aussieht und als ich das auch vor allem selber geglaubt hatte, ich dachte, da wäre nicht so viel Voodoo drin, sind aber eine ganze Menge Ideen reingeflossen, also der ist richtig designt. Und ich finde ja auch QR-Codes nicht scheiße. Also ihr wisst ja noch, ich habe doch mal diese Webseite mit peoplewhoscanqrcodes.com Ich erinnere mich dunkel. Wo dann irgendwie nichts war, because nobody is doing it. Aber dem ist ja nicht so, also es ist ja sehr wohl verbreitet. Zum Beispiel ist jetzt Sonntag hier die neue, diese neue Talk, neue alte Talkshow mit dem Böhmermann. Und wie heißt sein Kollege?
Oli Schulz, der Boxer? Nee, das wäre aber auch nicht.
Irgendwas mit Schulz.
Ach, der hieß auch Axel Schulz.
Das ist ein Remake von der Sendung, die er schon mal mit der Charlotte Roche gemacht hat.
Aber die Sendung ist ja immer Arsch die Sendung. Die wurden auf Twitter von Mario Bart gelobt.
Böhmermann getwittert.
Er gibt dir so eine Mühe, dann machst du eine schöne neue Sendung.
Das war das halte Konzept, ein bisschen anders eingepackt, aber auch wieder mit Vorstellungstexten, nur dass das nicht von diesem Hansel vorgelesen wird, den er jetzt schon in seiner Show mit drin hat. Sie haben sich dann wie eine Bille Berg geschnappt, die im Prinzip als Vorstellungstext einen Text in der Kategorie einer Spiegelkolumne geschrieben hat. Sehr cool. Diesen Einspieler haben sie dann wiederum mit einem QR-Code auf dem Fernseher ausgeliefert. Da dachte ich mir auch, machst du das jetzt? Manchmal werden ja auch QR-Codes in der Öffentlichkeit in einem Maße gezeigt, dass du sie dann auch nicht gescannt bekommst. Schlecht aufgelöstet. Das ging zumindest mit dem Fernseher, wo ich da gerade davor saß, ganz gut. Einfach war dann ein Link auf der Seite, wo dann eben nochmal genau das Ding zu holen war. Fand ich auf jeden Fall ganz gut. Aber von solchen Sachen, vor allem im Bereich Werbung, ganz abgesehen, QR-Codes werden einfach immer praktischer an vielen Stellen. So was weiß ich, das WLAN-Passwort in einem Café scannen und nicht eintippen müssen, so eine Sache. Es gibt einfach sehr viele gute Methoden, wobei der Bereich Security natürlich auch noch so eine Sache ist. Wenn du dich noch hier an diesen Android-Bug oder mit einer beliebigen URL so ein Security-Problem triggern konntest, hätte ich am liebsten auch Berlin irgendwie die Werbeplakate mit großen... Jetzt bilden sie eine Million Euro. Das wäre dann auch sehr schön günstig gewesen. Jetzt aber zurück zu diesem Talk. Er hat erst mal erklärt, wie QR überhaupt an sich funktioniert. Und dabei eben die Möglichkeiten aufgedeckt, wie man damit halt so Sachen machen kann. Und was ja jeder kennt, ist, dass so in QR-Codes mal ein Logo reingeklebt ist und so weiter. Das geht halt im Wesentlichen, weil du eben so eine Federkorrektur angeben kannst. Das heißt, so bestimmte Bits sind dann im Prinzip egal, wenn du malst, mit irgendwas überopferst, sozusagen, dann auch deine Fehlerkorrektur für Optik. Und dann hat das aber eben noch so ein paar, ja, da hat er so den Regler so auf 11 gestellt und so die Methoden gezeigt, wie man, ja, da kann ich, jetzt setzt das so ein bisschen bei mir aus, aber im Prinzip davon ausgehend, wie man analysiert hat, was so hinten rauskommt, dreht man quasi diesen ganzen Produktionsprozess um und geht sozusagen von einem Endergebnis, was man gerne haben will, so Backtracking-mäßig auf das, wie denn der Code dann eigentlich sein müsste, damit man irgendwie das entsprechende Ergebnis bekommt, weil es halt für alles irgendwie verschiedene Varianten und Musterkategorien gibt, etc. Also es ist ein sehr mehrdimensionaler Ansatz und das ist auch alles noch nicht fertig, da ist schon Software entstanden, da entsteht noch mehr Software, aber wer irgendwie keine Angst hat vor naja so Medium-Algorithmik, das ist jetzt auch nicht, wir reden jetzt hier nicht von High-Level-Informatiker-Kram, da muss ich im Wesentlichen einfach mal konzentriert hinsetzen und das verstehen, könnte man da wirklich mal nette QR-Codes rausgenerieren, die ja sehr viel mehr noch ein Logo sind, als das heute der Fall ist. Auf jeden Fall eine Empfehlung von mir, ein schöner Talk. Ja, also solange wir noch Talks haben, die wir empfehlen können und die irgendeiner von uns gesehen hat.
Nee Tim, das kann man nicht machen, weil dann sitzt man hier wieder irgendwie die halbe Nacht, also da muss man irgendwo eine Grenze ziehen.
Das ist hier sowieso die halbe Nacht.
Ich weiß nicht, was, haben sie dir so erzählt, was die übliche Laufzeit dieser Sendung ist?
Ich kenne die, ich glaube, ich habe jede einzelne Freak Show gehört.
Ich wurde ja tatsächlich gestern auf der Straße erkannt. Was muss mit dieser Live-Show zu tun haben, wo jetzt irgendwie auch echte Gesichter an den Stimmen kleben. Auf der anderen Straßenseite schiebt gerade ein jemand so seinen Fahrrad lang Hallo, ich grüße dich, ja und guckst so rüber Huckel? Ich kam dann rüber, hat gut Hallo gesagt und dass er Freak Show hört und super. Das ist immer bald hier mit Sonnenbrille und gut und falsch im Bad rumlaufen. Das ist ja eher die Ausnahmezirge. Also weil jetzt ja gerade nicht so die Leute vorspringen mit Talks, gibt es hier noch eine kleine Empfehlung am Rande für alle Hörer, die da waren und die die unfassbare Lounge bzw. den Club gesehen haben und sich schon immer gefragt haben ist das eigentlich immer hier? Also ist das hier also ist das CCHR oder was oder wie? Gibt es von den Bachstelzen, die uns immer da tatkräftig unterstützen beim Aufbau dieser epischen Veranstaltungslocation Fotoalbum auf Facebook, das auch ohne Facebook-Account eingesehen werden kann. Ich habe den Link jetzt hier schon in den Chat getan. Alle mal klicken und weiter verteilen und darüber freuen und staunen, was man aus so einer Lagerhalle im Wesentlichen doch nicht alles zaubern kann. Ich weiß nicht, weißt du, wie lange die da eigentlich dran bauen dann an dieser Lounge? Also...
Die können frühestens am 18. angefangen haben. Aber ich glaube, dass sie das nicht...
Am 17. sind die ersten angerollt.
Ja, aber am 18. durfte man glaube ich ins Gebäude. Und... Ich glaube, so am 20. hörte ich erst das Raunen von der Lounge. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig konzentriert habe.
Die müssen euch echt mögen, weil ich kann dir sagen, dass du in der Regel in den Veranstaltungsort so lange vorher rein kannst, ist sehr, sehr ungewöhnlich.
Na ja, die mögen uns.
Aus Gänsefüßchen, aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen Gänsefüßchen.
Na, es gibt da halt den Sonderfall Weihnachten.
Ist egal.
Und den Sonderfall, das ist ja Versicherungstechnisch, die Veranstaltung beginnt dann.
Ihr habt Glück, dass das so ist, weil ich bin gerade diese Woche wieder dadurch genervt worden, dass ich irgendwelche Spanken, die eine total leere Halle hatten, wo man in Ruhe mal was hätte tun können. Aber sie haben den Veranstaltungsraum erst ab morgen gemietet. Ja, ich will hier auch gar nicht veranstalten, ich will dir ein Kabel ziehen. Nein. Na ja, okay, komme ich morgen wieder. Weißt du, so aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen Gänsefüßchen zu.
Na ja, das ist schlecht organisiert.
Ja, aber diesen Lounge-Aufbau, den muss man einfach mal gesehen haben. Also überhaupt die, ja, den Club-Club.
Den Club-Club. Ist immer wieder eine Show. Wie gesagt, wir waren ja früher in Berlin, hat ja das Art und das Beauty irgendwann schwer gelitten unter den ganzen Teilnehmern und dem nicht zur Verfügung stehenden Expansionsraum. Deswegen war es ja am Ende eigentlich fast gar kein Art und Beauty mehr und die letzte Lounge in Berlin oder der Club-Club, das hat ja überhaupt gar nicht diesen Namen mehr verdient gehabt. Das war ja so eine Raucherhöhle, ne? Das war ja wirklich nur noch ein Loch im Wesentlichen. Und das ist wirklich im CCH einfach so eine fette Installation. Jedes Jahr aufs Neue, jedes Jahr anders, jedes Jahr krass, gut. Und ja, wie gesagt, diesmal gibt es eben dann diese schönen Fotos da zu sehen, um das auch mal ja, sich vor Augen zu finden. Dass diese Installation nicht so immer da ist und sie sieht halt auch jedes Mal so aus, als wäre das einfach so eine permanente Installation. Ich denke mir auch jedes Mal, ah, wenn das immer hier wäre, das wäre der Nerdclub TM, ne?
Du würdest, also wenn du das Ding, wenn du nimmst dir eine Halle in Berlin, Hamburg oder sonst was, stellst den schnille Fix da rein, ne? Da hast du Umsätze, die du damit fahren würdest, in dem ersten Monat, ne? Also das wäre einfach sofort mal der coolste Club der Stadt.
Aber ich glaube, wenn du das wieder für Geld machst und so, dann...
Dann wär's nicht so geil.
Dann, ja, das fühlt er nicht richtig. Auch die Leute, die das machen und die Leute, die hinkommen, auch nicht. Kannste halt nicht replizieren. So, also ohne mit, ohne good intentions.
Ja, die Leute, die das machen, machen das auch nicht zum ersten Mal und sind nicht umsonst die, die besten ihrer Zunft.
Was mich immer wieder flasht, ist übrigens diese Holzbar. Als ich die das erste Mal gesehen hab, da war die, weiß nicht, war die beim ersten Kongress schon da in Hamburg?
30C3.
Ja, und da dachte ich mir schon, wow, die sieht ja aus wie, also wirklich jetzt hier ganz individuell reingeschreien hat und die ist einfach, die wird auch nur wieder zerhackt, also so richtig so mit der Flex und so wieder abgebaut. Nächstes Jahr steht die einfach genauso wieder da und sieht wieder mit Spinnenweben, also wirklich, da war ja wirklich einfach jedes Detail, ja, da ist irgendwie Schmand an den Lampen dran, Spinnenweben hier und so weiter und du siehst auch null, dass das irgendwie so ein Baukastensystem ist, ja. Dann als die auf dem Camp war, noch mal abgedreht, nein, das darf da jetzt nicht wahr sein, wirklich. Und ja, also schon alleine diese Bar flasht mich irgendwie jedes Mal wieder aufs Neue, aufgrund der Detailverliebtheit und offensichtlich der Modularität, dass sie die irgendwie so kompakt weglagern können und wieder genauso verranst aufbauen können, als hätte sie schon 20 Jahre da genauso gestanden. Echt, also Respekt. Das ist ganz vorne mit dabei.
Geht was. Wo ist denn der Link hier eigentlich? Meist ihr doch mal bitte auch hier in unser Ding Sie rein.
Hab ich doch schon. Das war diese Facebook-Uhr 11.
Ach, Facebook.
Hast du die jetzt rausgelöscht? Nein, nein, nein. Doch, hast du.
Du hast hier einfach die Sachen. Ja doch. Der ist unten unter in dem eingeklappten...
Ach, Dekoration Lounge.
Ich mach den mal wieder da hin.
Ich hab's schon in den Chat gepostet, sollte der Verschonote sein.
Diese Liste wird ja dann später mal in Show Notes. Deswegen hier sozusagen immer, da wo wir gerade sind, einfach mal reinschmeißen.
Da ist es genau. Nee, jetzt streichst du quasi das durch, wo ich... Das ist aber ein sehr großes Lack, dieses System, was ihr hier verwendet. Wie heißt das?
Workflow-y.
Also ich muss mal sagen, hatte ich auch schon mal gesagt, also eine der wenigen Apps, die Sync in bisher so in richtig hinbekommen hat, ist ja dieses Ohrwunderlist, wo man sich immer fragt, brauche ich jetzt wirklich eine App für eine To-do-Liste? Hab ich mir lange Zeit gedacht, aber eins muss man denen wirklich lassen, da ist Syncing so, wie ich das erwarte. Direkt sofort und mit Bumzack-Return und so. Erhält von mir das Bumzack-Return-Siegel, einfach auch nur, weil ich es bisher noch nicht besser gesehen habe. Noch nicht benutzt.
Hat auf jeden Fall auch immer sehr akkurat gesüngt.
Aber das Workflow muss ich auch sagen, das ist der Strich über dem Ding.
Besser als durch, weil gerade hatten wir dann einen über... Ach komm, lass mal. Das ist Software von gestern.
Das Workflow ist einfach der einzige Outliner.
Ich weiß. Aber was mich ja auch mal interessieren würde, Tim, zeig mir mal einen gesellten Outliner. Was ich auch wichtig fände, Tim, wäre ein Kalender.
Das Thema ist durch, er bleibt ja gelöst jetzt. Naja, also zumindest ist der Schmerz so stark, Linda, dass du schon lange nicht mehr darüber gesprochen hast.
Als aufgegeben.
Tim gibt nicht auf.
Tim hat einfach jetzt erkannt.
Das muss schon irgendwie besser geworden sein. Also, er tragbar zumindest.
Die Menge an Dingen, die ich scheiße finde, ist jetzt nicht so groß, dass ich da jetzt Bock drauf hätte, eine halbe Stunde drüber zu ran.
Das war mal anders, deutlich.
Entweder liegt es daran, dass sie es gefixt haben, oder Tim ist einfach älter geworden.
Ich glaube, Tim hat bei solchen Sachen eigentlich nicht locker.
Vorder ist nicht heraus.
Ich bin wirklich zufrieden mit der Gesamtsituation, aber kann jetzt auch nicht immer wieder dasselbe schreien. Wollen wir jetzt nochmal hier vorwärts kommen?
Radio-Batch muss man würdigen. Kann man nicht umhin.
Dann würdige das doch mal. Du hast aber den Talk gar nicht gesehen.
Gab's den? Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen. Ich hab einen Radio-Batch, war ja auf dem Camp. Die haben einen weiterentwickelt.
Ja, sicher, schön. Jetzt so richtig schöne neue Software-Versionen, neue Features und so.
Ja, naja, also so mega viel ist jetzt nicht passiert. Sie hatten ja ursprünglich vor, auch eine überarbeitete zweite, also entweder eine weitere Auflage zu machen oder vielleicht auch eine weiterentwickelte Version. Dazu ist es jetzt nicht gekommen. Das wundert mich aber auch nicht, weil...
Wo ist der nächste Camp?
Ja, keine Ahnung, aber das war jetzt, sagen wir mal, zumindest in diesem kurzen Zeitraum nicht so gut. Der Talk ist halt für alle Leute, die auf dem Camp waren und die so ein Radio rumliegen haben und sich immer schon mal gewundert haben, was sie damit hinbekommen könnten. Sehr gut, weil es ein paar Anregungen, ein paar Ideen gibt, aber vor allem eben auch, sagen sie halt sehr ehrlich, was eben auch nicht funktioniert hat. Also im Prinzip ist der ganze Talk so eine Bucklist mit Workarounds, wo es welche gibt. Also dass man einfach die Limitierung des Gerätes kennt und wenn man Limitierungen kennt, dann ist eigentlich alles schon mal ganz gut.
Aber ich finde das jetzt, die haben in drei Monaten einiges geschafft. Und ich finde das witzig, dass in diesem Podcast wird normalerweise irgendwie jedes neue Apple Betriebssystem Feature in Länge diskutiert. Und dann haben die in drei Monaten was gemacht und du sagst, da ist nicht viel passiert. Bei deiner Apple Watch ist nicht viel passiert.
Das waren ja ihre eigenen Worte in ihrem Talk. Dass sie sagten, es sei jetzt seit dem Camp nicht viel passiert, weil sie einfach die Zeit gar nicht gefunden haben. Da jetzt selber, also es gibt keine neue Version, es gibt keine, von der Hardware mal nicht. Klar, an der Software ist geschraubt worden.
Gold haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Und sie haben halt auch, was weiß ich, die haben ja diese App gehabt, die auf dem Congress, die Funk-DMX-Steuerung von der Lounge lief dann halt auch auf diesen Radio-Badges.
Ja, nicht die Steuerung, oder?
Mir war nicht ganz klar, wie das aufgebaut ist, aber wie ich es rausgehört habe, gab es eine funkbasierte DMX, funkbasierte Steuerung der Lichteffekte auf dem Dancefloor. Und die Radios konnten das halt mit empfangen, mit dekodieren und dann auch selber quasi mit ihren LEDs entsprechendes Leuchtfeuer machen.
Das Problem war, du musstest die LEDs dran gelötet haben.
Ja, das war jetzt auch nicht for everybody. Und es gab halt so ein paar stolze Nerds, die dann halt mit diesem Schild da vor der Brust rumgelaufen sind, so wie man sich Nerds halt so vorstellt. Und das ist auch alles total super. Ist jetzt noch nicht so ganz die Anwendung, wo ich sagen würde, Radio hat jetzt die App des Jahres bekommen, weil die anderen Apps, die sie halt vorgestellt haben, waren halt so im Bereich Pont Tetris.
Das entscheidende an einem Radio ist nicht, was irgendwie auf diesem Nokia-Display abgeht.
Nein, das ist schon klar. Aber da habe ich halt auch nichts von gesehen. Also es gab jetzt keine Präsentation, wo jetzt mal irgendjemand wirklich sendend empfängt in irgendeiner Kombination. Die Hacks waren jetzt so noch nicht da. Und ich glaube, das hat auch einfach was damit zu tun, dass die Leute, die sie jetzt damit wirklich intensiv auseinandersetzen, ist wahrscheinlich eher überschaubar. Und die werden vielleicht noch ein bisschen Zeit brauchen. Ich habe gar keinen Zweifel, dass da noch was dabei rauskommt. Nur in diesem Talk war halt jetzt nichts drin. Ist also für Leute, die damit konkret entwickeln wollen, ein guter Hintergrund-Talk. Ja, weiß nicht, wollen wir die anderen Sachen hier noch ansprechen?
Ich würde ja schon die Intro-Animation zumindest wollen. Das musst du machen, Tim.
Ach so. Haben wir da nicht schon drüber gesprochen?
Hier noch nicht? Nee, das ist klar. Ja, es gab ein schönes Intro-Video. Lob das doch mal, Tim.
Ja, also was ja nicht so meinem Wunsch entsprach, war, dass wieder einmal Motto und Design auf den letzten Metern festgelegt wurden. Gut, ist so gewesen und dann muss man damit leben, war dann trotzdem wieder relativ beeindruckt davon, wie viele Varianten das dann aufgegriffen wurde. Wobei ich mir dann am Ende nicht so sicher war, in wie vielen von diesen Varianten Roland selber auch noch mal seine Finger mit drin hatte oder wirklich andere Leute das gemacht haben. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel, wir hatten auch so ein Sendezentrum in 32C3, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer das gemacht hat. Ja, siehst du mal, das war so ein bisschen meine Vermutung, weil das war dann eben auch so gut, dass ich jetzt nicht unbedingt den Eindruck hatte, dass das jetzt von...
Von Ralf wäre.
Ja, oder von wem auch immer wäre. Es gab ja auch andere Gruppen, die das eben auch hatten, also Seidenstraße etc. Aber das ist ja auch schön, das fand ich gut, dass das sich eben so breiten Raum gegriffen hat. Trotzdem sind wir halt seit dem 29C3 nicht wieder da hingekommen, wo wir schon mal waren beim 29C3. Wo wir wirklich ein Design hatten, auf einer Ebene, wie ich mir das halt für diesen Kongress vorstelle.
Den will ich auch widersprechen, weil du hast eigentlich immer bei dem Design, also da will ich widersprechen, dass das beim 29C3 unbedingt so war. Diese Designsachen zerbrechen relativ schnell, wenn jemand sie anfasst, der das nicht 100% verstanden hat. Das war bei dem 29C3 mit dem Not My Department. Wir müssen irgendwelche Buchstaben anordnen. Das hat auch nicht wirklich funktioniert, wenn es jemand angefasst hat, der das Konzept nicht, oder der nicht eine gestalterische Hand dafür hatte. Das hat beim 30C3, da gab es eigentlich auch nur mehr oder weniger dieses Logo, bei dem 31C3 mit dem Powerbutton. So Dinge funktionieren nicht so einfach, dass es jemand aufgreift. Die gehen halt kaputt. Es sieht dann aus, wie wenn irgendjemand versucht, das Coca-Cola-Logo zu malen. Das kriegst du hin, aber das sieht man dann halt nicht so.
Das ist eine Frage der Werkzeuge, die du bereitstellst. Beim 29C3 war es halt so, es gab zum Beispiel Javascript-Code. Den konntest du auf beliebigen Text anwenden, und dann war der halt 29C3-ig. Und zwar exakt genau so, wie alles andere 29C3-ig war, weil es halt mit demselben Code gemacht wurde. Und das, finde ich, ist etwas, was wir da einfach insgesamt anstreben sollten. Dass man Design auch in Code denkt. Nicht nur in Code denkt, auch in Code denkt, aber überhaupt weiter denkt. Dass das nicht nur, ich hab da ein Logo mit einer Designlinie, und das wenden wir jetzt auf vieles an, sondern dass man Design der Veranstaltung denkt als Teil des Gesamtmechanismus. Dass die Gestaltung nicht nur eine optische Gestaltung ist, sondern die eine starke Funktion auch hat. Die man auch zum Beispiel in physischen Objekten auch wiederfinden kann.
Wir hatten eine 3D-Druck-Challenge.
Ich meine jetzt nicht Logo nachdrucken.
Ich weiß, was du meinst. Aber ich glaube, dass dieses Ziel, wie so viele Ziele, von denen du begeistert bist, sehr schwer zu erreichen ist.
Ja, aber so sind alle Ziele, die wir uns beim Kongress jemals gestellt haben, waren schwer zu erreichen. Aber es ist halt immer dasselbe Lied. 300% anstreben, 150% erreichen. Das ist die Geschichte dieser Veranstaltungs-Serie. Und da muss man halt erstmal wirr und weit und nee, das geht doch gar nicht denken. Und dann wird man halt feststellen, dass sehr wohl vieles davon geht. Und wenn man einfach nicht völlig übergeschnappt und wahnwitzig an so eine Sachen herangeht, dann wird man am Ende keine korrekte Exzellenz ernten.
Ich glaube, das war's.
Ich will damit nicht sagen...
Ich wollte auch gerade mal so kurz mal hier so einen Anker werfen, aber bitte, bitte jetzt dein Aber.
Ja, ich finde, ich finde, dass das Design, was der Roland abgeworfen hat, mit seinem Bruder zusammen, der daran gearbeitet hat...
Also Roland hat im Prinzip so dieses gesamte Konzept gemacht, mit dieser in einer Linie durchgeführt und diese Idee mit den Flaschen, mit den unterschiedlichen Inhalten. Und sein Bruder Frederik hat die 3D-Animation gemacht. Das sieht man bei den Congress Recordings, wenn man da so diese Doppelview hat. Unten rechts sieht man immer, wie sich das 32C3 und das gated communities in so einem 3D-Objekt bewegen. Und dann gibt es eben beim Opening, beim Jahresrückblick und beim Closing haben wir dieses, wie nennt man sowas, Opener-Animation abgespielt, wo Frederik dann halt einfach mal so im Blender gezeigt hat, was man mit diesem Tool so machen kann.
Das scheint er ganz gut im Griff zu haben.
Das scheint er ganz gut im Griff, ja. Das ist, glaube ich, kann man so sagen.
Das war schon ziemlich fett.
Und dann halt nachher noch der Erich Lesowski, ein, wie nennt man sowas, Audio-Engineer oder Audio-Magiker, Zauberer. Wie heißt das nochmal? Ton?
Ton-Engineer?
Ton-Engineer. Ich weiß nicht, wie. Der Typ für den Ton, der hat im Prinzip das komplette Video in Mute bekommen. Es gab keine Audiospur zu dem Video. Das Video war fertig und wurde dann halt dem Erich gegeben. Der ist dann halt ein paar Tage weg untergetaucht und kam dann eben mit diesem Sound, dieser Tonspur zu dem Video zurück. Was ich auch sehr krass fand, dass man das so quasi wirklich vollständig getrennt voneinander entwickelt in der Form. Das fand ich sehr spannend. Im Chat habe ich den Link zum Originalvideo, wenn du das jetzt abspielen möchtest. Da, genau.
Ich dachte, den Sound könnte man vielleicht nochmal...
Kann man machen, ja. Gehst du auf Continue jetzt?
Wieso ist denn da noch kein...
Weil die Domain Terror im Namen hat und dann Let's Encrypt aus vielleicht nachvollziehbaren Gründen dir nicht automatisch ein Zertifikat gibt.
Was?
Scheint so zu sein.
Oh Mann, nein. Vorsicht, Moment.
Positero kriegt dann auch keiner.
Okay, vielleicht habe ich aber auch einen Fehler gemacht und bin einfach nur... Es kann auch sein, dass das jetzt funktionieren würde, aber ich habe ja alle meine Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate schon vor der Public Beta über freundliche E-Mails geholt. Von den ganzen Domains, wo ich gesagt habe, hier, da müsste ich jetzt mal testen, war halt Terrorbyte eine, wo der Request dann irgendwie pending war.
Ich spiele mal hier den Sound ein, weil wir gerade darüber reden. Also das korrespondiert schon sehr schön mit dem Video, was halt auch so Matrix-Referenzen hat. Es war halt auch alles krass schwarz-weiß alles, ne?
Ja, man kennt mich ja nicht unbedingt als Freund der Farbe. Orange, das muss ich einfach noch wegmachen.
Aber soundmäßig, gerade hier, die Stelle.
Hammer, oder? Darf ich aber auch loben, weil die Vereinbarung war, weil das Video doch schon sehr aufwendig ist, weil so die Vereinbarung... Ich hab da nichts zu sagen. Ich durfte da keinerlei Einfluss drauf nehmen. Und deswegen kann ich das im vollen Umfang loben. Du sagst, okay, wir machen das. Aber du sagst nichts. Du hast keinerlei Einfluss. Du sagst, wenn das fertig ist, dann nimmst du das oder nicht? Ja. Und dann bin ich halt aus dem Staunen nicht mehr rausgekommen, als ich gesehen hab, was meine lieben Freunde da dieser Veranstaltung geschenkt haben. Das hat mich sehr gefreut.
Ja, ich finde das auch sehr schön. Ich weiß nicht, ich überleg gerade, das wievielte Congress-Intro-Video das jetzt überhaupt ist. Also ich glaube, wir hatten vier oder fünf jetzt?
Wir sind nicht.
Letztes Jahr eins? Ja, letztes Jahr hätten wir eins haben können, wenn das nicht auf den letzten Mittag noch gescheitert war oder gab es noch eins?
Ich war letztes Jahr.
Das Falk hat dann auch irgendwas gemacht und dann hat das irgendwas nicht geklappt. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, ich glaube, letztes Jahr gab es...
Ich glaube auch.
Bei den Vogue-Intros gibt es aber so eine ganz schöne Animation, die ein bisschen spielt mit dem...
Ich mein, jetzt ist es halt so ein richtig knalliger Opener.
Na ja, also das, was beim 30C3 gemacht wurde, ist halt auch irgendwie nicht mehr zu toppen. Also an Falkstelle hätte ich dann auch gesagt, ich bin ja nicht verrückt.
Das hatte wieder was dann mit der knappen Zeit zu tun, was halt eigentlich immer das Hauptproblem ist. Und dann gab es, glaube ich, beim 22 und 23C3, gab es schon mal sowas. Und dann ist das irgendwie lange in Vergessenheit geraten.
Das ist ja auch, ich meine wirklich, also ich meine, das ist natürlich schön. Da freue ich mich auch, wenn das Auge was zu gucken hat und alles irgendwie toll und fantastisch ist. Aber bei so einer Veranstaltung, die sowieso vor allen Dingen von Freiwilligen hauptsächlich organisiert wird und die Leute, die das da hauptfederführend in der Hand haben, sozusagen sowieso sich so einen mega Job übers Kreuz ziehen, dass da dann sozusagen die Gestaltung immer auch, oder sagen wir mal oft in den vergangenen Kongressen, so auf dem letzten Meter noch so, ja. Muss nicht, aber ich habe auch Verständnis dafür. Ich war ja schon oft genug involviert in diesen Prozess. Und ja, wir müssten mal die sein und kennt man mal wem, der das jetzt mal machen könnte. Und dann ist ja natürlich auch die Ansage, ja, gibt auch nichts dafür, ne. Und dann musst du halt auch schon so Überzeugungstäter aus dem Nerd-Kontext finden, die aber auch gleichzeitig einen coolen Style haben. Und die Kombination ist jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, nicht so super ausgeprägt, ne.
Was ist nicht super ausgeprägt?
Na, diese Kombination von so im Dunstkreis CCC, also total auch... Ja, aber in der Kombination mit Zeit. Und vor allen Dingen Zeit, jetzt sich kostenlos sozusagen oder ohne Entgelt darum zu kümmern. Und das ist ja auch nicht nur jetzt mal irgendwie ein Design so konzeptionell ausdenken. Du machst ja tausend Sachen da, theoretisch noch. Also hier T-Shirts und so weiter. Das ist ja alles auch Arbeit, dauert alles Zeit.
Was ist das für ein Argument?
Wenn du halt vier Wochen vorher ankommst und sagst so, ja...
Dann kannst du auch sagen, ja, nee, Netzwerk, das war jetzt... Also, das haben wir auch so viel Arbeit hier.
Ja, aber das ist bei der Veranstaltung einfach das Unwichtigste von allem, wirklich. Was ist das Unwichtigste? Also, erst mal muss Netzwerk und alles, andere Talks und so weiter stehen. Und wenn sich dann noch um Design gekümmert wird, super.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, dem muss ich leider vollkommen widersprechen. Das kann ja wohl nicht dein Ernst sein.
Sondern der Paul, der hat die Mütze vom Ernst aus.
Dieser Kongress, schau dir an, wie der sich gerade in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat. Und was der in zunehmenden Maße ist, der ist in zunehmenden Maße eine gesamtkulturelle Veranstaltung, die immer breiter sich ausstellt.
Genau, das wird ja jetzt auch immer mehr. Aber so gerade so den Bezug auf die Vergangenheit fände ich halt auch unfair, weil das ja auch alles jetzt quasi so gewachsen ist.
Wie du meinst, welchen Bezug auf die Vergangenheit?
Na, weil du meintest, hier seitdem, was weiß ich...
Ach so, ja, das meinte ich nur, weil bei 29C3, da habe ich das Licht gesehen. Weil da war ja eine Designertruppe am Start, die hat sich mal echt lange Zeit Gedanken gemacht und die haben da wirklich so einen Spin gehabt, der einfach auch super gepasst hat. Und nichts... Das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass wir nicht in der Lage sind, das zu iterieren.
Natürlich sind wir. Aber bitte können wir dann ganz kurz, also bevor jetzt irgendwie noch eine halbe Stunde irgendwie über das Design rund ist...
Du wolltest über das Design reden? Jetzt rede ich über das Design.
Ja, okay, dann reden wir doch mal da. Dann würde ich doch vielleicht ganz gerne darüber sprechen, was der Grund ist, warum das Design immer in kurzer Zeit gemacht werden muss. Und das liegt ja nicht daran, dass irgendwie die Designer pennen, weil sie irgendwie ihren Shit nicht zusammen haben, sondern es liegt daran, dass sie diese ver- Das stimmt ja auch alles nicht. Das Problem ist, dass es jedes Jahr vor dem Kongress eine sehr ausgeprägte Diskussion über das Motto gibt, die auch du, mein lieber Sohn, Brutus, über mehrere Monate geführt hast, bis dann irgendwann der Hammer fiel und gesagt wurde, folgendes ist das Motto.
Ich hab die Diskussion überhaupt nicht geführt. Ich hab einen Vorschlag gemacht, gesagt, der ist gut, den kann man nehmen. Dann wollte den keiner nehmen. Ich hab nicht eine Diskussion geführt. Da bin ich schon vollkommen von befreit. Ich will nicht über das Motto diskutieren, weil wenn ich eins weiß, was nichts bringt, ist über das Motto diskutieren. Das Motto wird festgelegt von irgendjemanden, der nicht rechtzeitig festgebunden werden konnte. Und dann kümmert man sich, dass man diese Welt, die diese Grundidee versucht auszufüllen, dass man die breit designmäßig, gesamtgestaltungsmäßig in diesen Event reinbringt, so gut es geht. Und da kann man nächsten Monat mit anfangen.
Das ist wie die Amis mit ihrem Supporter Groups, ne?
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Grund, 10 Monate da jetzt zu warten, um dann so im letzten Moment so, oh ja, was haben wir denn hier? Also wir haben jetzt irgendwie alles gemietet, Talks, irgendwie Netz, da war noch was, da war noch was. Scheiße Motto! Das kommt ja immer so.
Ja, aber wenn dir das so wichtig ist, dann kümmer du dich doch darum, das zu organisieren.
Deswegen, Roddi, ich hab das vor ein mehrfach angeboten, aber das wurde ja nicht angenommen.
Und lass uns mal hören, das Spiel ist jetzt vorbei, was hattest du denn angeboten?
Ne, das ist alles, äh, der kann jeder behaupten, was er Tim angeboten hat, kann er jetzt nicht sagen, weil er für nächstes Jahr nochmal vorschlagt.
Nein, das ist auch überhaupt nicht wichtig, mir geht es jetzt auch nicht darum, mich jetzt so hinzustellen, mit... Ich sag nur, es kann, es ist nicht so, dass das nicht geht, so. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass das so neu ist, und es ist auch nicht so, dass dem keinen Wert entgegengebracht wird. Also wenn du sagst, das sei jetzt das Unwichtigste, dann kann ich dir 30.000 andere Sachen auf diesem Kongress zeigen, die sind genauso das Unwichtigste und die werden trotzdem mit Vehemenz und mit Exzellenz betrieben, bis hin zu Galoge über Markenröse. Ja, was? Und das Design ist halt auch wichtig, weil das einfach...
Und wurde auch mit Vehemenz und Exzellenz betrieben.
Genau, und das wurde dann auch auf den letzten Metern mit Vehemenz und Exzellenz betrieben, hat aber immer maximalen Stressfaktor für die Leute. Das finde ich halt so furchtbar, dass die Leute, die das dann noch alles retten, immer noch so einen mega Druck arbeiten müssen, der überhaupt nicht sein muss.
Aber ich finde das sehr schön, dass du jetzt über die Belastungen rantest, die irgendwie Roland und ich hatten. Weil am Ende haben wir das Ding ja ausgelöffelt.
Ja, natürlich. Ich kenne das ja auch. Beim 31C3 war es halt Sven und ich sehe das immer aus ungebarer Nähe.
Das war immer so.
Nein, das war nicht immer so.
Na ja, gefühlt. Also ich habe das ja auch schon lange genug...
21C3 hatten wir im Mai alles im Kasten. Das ganze Design stand, Logo, alles war da.
Ungehackt, aber...
Wir haben das schon ein paar Mal auch richtig gemacht. Es ist nicht so, dass... Ich sage nur, es ist nicht so, dass wir das noch nicht hatten. Also wir waren da auch schon mal besser und wir müssen da auch wieder hin und dann müssen wir von da noch weiter nach vorn. Vorwärts nach weit, wie Kutschwitt das sagen würde.
Gut.
Ja, nur...
Ich muss michern.
Ich war tanzen.
Der Kongress ist einfach ein Gesamtkunstwerk und so müssen wir den auch denken und da gibt es irgendwie nichts ist wichtiger, ist weniger wichtig.
Ist alles wichtig.
Aber irgendwie, also was mich jetzt eigentlich so an dieser Ansprache quasi nur so ein bisschen aneckt stört, wie auch immer, ist halt so quasi die Formulierung als Forderung, wo du ja genau weißt, dass das alles so freiwilliger erfordert ist. Und du jetzt ja nicht so eine Stelle hast, wo du das jetzt so einklagen kannst, sondern frag nicht, wer das Design für den Klub machen kann, sondern frag, was du für das Design für den Klub machst.
Es war irgendwie dieses Jahr auch noch mal so ein Camp. Und irgendwann sind halt so Ende September Leute aufgestanden und haben gesagt, ach, scheiße, hat sich eigentlich schon jemand um den Congress gekümmert. Und dann gab es irgendwie so...
Linus, es war doch vor dem Camp genau dasselbe. Es war doch auch einen Monat vor dem Camp.
Hat dir das Campdesign nicht gefallen? Das hab ich zufällig zusammen mit Sven gemacht.
Mir hat das Design dieses Jahr vom Congress gefallen. Mir haben die ganzen letzten Designs gefallen.
Wir hätten nur früher anfangen müssen, damit wir weniger Stress haben. Und mehr.
Nein, weil mich am Ende immer alle Gestalter da sitzen. Es war nicht genug Zeit, um das noch zu machen. Ich wollte das noch machen. Die wollen sich auch ausleben. Die wollen auch Raum haben. Man muss den Leuten Raum geben.
Man muss allen Raum geben. Okay, das war am Anfang auch ein bisschen unklar formuliert. Die Forderung ist, mehr Zeit für Design.
Genau, weil man darüber auch viel leiten kann. Wenn das früh draußen ist, wenn da Frühsources draußen sind, wenn da vielleicht Code draußen ist, wenn da Vektor-Grafiken draußen sind und so weiter, dann haben wir auch wirklich den kompletten Kongress in 3D geplottet.
Aber vielleicht können wir ja noch mal ein bisschen darauf eingehen, was trotz der unglaublich widrigen Umstände, unter denen der Tim so gelitten hat, entstanden ist. Zum Beispiel hier, was ich mit sehr viel Stolz trage, ist ja dieser Zipper. Ich war ja nebenbei noch ein bisschen verantwortlich.
Du weißt schon, dass das ein Audio-Podcast ist.
Ich war ja nebenbei so ein bisschen, aber ich möchte trotzdem für euch jetzt auch eine kleine Runde angeben. Ich war ja nebenbei noch verantwortlich für die Produktion der Klamotten, Zipper und so weiter. Ich habe dann am liebsten diese Bootleg-Ware vom Raumzeitlabor mit Design aufgestickt, mit der Stickmaschine von Jiska. Die hat da Tag und Nacht an dem Ding gestanden und menschenfröhlich gemacht. Und dieses Garn hier ist sogar noch Leuchte im Dunkeln Garn. Also wenn du die...
Hast du ja zur Abschlussparty perfekt gepasst.
Ja genau, so eine Sachen müssen einfach breit aufgestellt sein.
Es war auch gar nicht so auf den letzten Drucker. Wir haben ganz freundlich für alle möglichen Leute Sachen gemacht. Und ich habe so ein bisschen versucht, dieses Design unter Verschluss zu halten, aus zwei Gründen. Der erste war, dass ich wusste, wenn jetzt alle ihre Stifte in die Hand nehmen, wird das nur in 25% der Fälle ein glückliches Ende finden. Und das andere war, dass es ja diesen Effekt mit dem Öffnen der Flasche gab. Und deswegen wollte ich nicht, dass zu viele die geöffnete Flasche schon sehen, die ja dann am Ende auf den T-Shirts war, wo sich ja alle vorher aufgeregt haben, wie langweilig die geschlossene Flasche aussah. Das war ja auch immer, immer wenn jemand auf Twitter irgendwie sich über die geschlossene Flasche aufregte, gab es einen grinsenden Linus zu Hause, der so... Warte nur, ja. Und andererseits musste ich ja auch mit meiner kleinen, das wahre Logo, seht ihr erst bei der Veranstaltung, ein bisschen Schadensbegrenzung machen, dass jetzt nicht auf einmal alle anfangen, Siebe vorzubereiten, ist passiert, Aufkleber zu drucken, ist passiert und sich zu viel auf diese geschlossene Flasche, die ja das weniger schöne der Logos war, einschießen. Deswegen haben wir aber dann unter der Hand, zum Beispiel auch so mit dem Raumzeitlabor und so, den Kontakt gehabt und gesagt, hier, pass auf, wir geben euch mal das vollständige Design, macht schon mal eure Stickmaschine warm, wandelt das schon mal so um, wie ihr das braucht und das kleine GTFO unter dem Wetterhahn muss auch GTFO sein und so. Und unten auf der Fußmatte am Haus muss FU stehen und so. Und das wurde dann auch alles gemacht. Und dann hat das halt so ein bisschen hinter den Kulissen stattgefunden.
Strategie.
Wofür ich auch Verständnis habe.
Würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht nochmal so machen, bin ich aber auch ganz ehrlich.
Ja, das ist immer so ein bisschen...
Du bist dann auf einmal...
Mir musst du nicht sagen, so ein Show-Effekt ist geil.
Ja, und dann gehen die undankbaren GSM-Leute hier und verkaufen an Tag 0 ihre SIM-Karten, wo das schöne, dicke Logo drauf ist. Aber hat dann auch keiner gesehen.
Die SIM-Karten bekommen... Das ist immer der Punkt. Ich warte immer schon jedes Jahr auf die Mail von den Leuten von den SIM-Karten. Ja, habt ihr mal einen Design für die SIM-Karten, weil wir müssen die jetzt mal in China drucken lassen. Und das ist dann immer so der Moment, wo so...
Dieses Mal war das für das, ich habe es zurückgeschrieben, selbstverständlich.
Was ich übrigens auch so einen kleinen Kongressmoment zwischendurch hatte, also was für ein, egal, Sprachzentrum, schon wieder angeschlagen hier vor dem Bier, standen wir so in der Lounge, haben irgendwie ein Konzert geguckt, im Club-Club, genau. Und dann gab es ja da eine Siebdruck-Werkstatt auch im Club-Club, ne? Also die haben ja da auch, neben dem Spaceballs-Camper, da haben die sich zwischen Bar und Spaceballs-Camper hat sich ja noch eine Siebdruck-Werkstatt eingenistet und hat auf dem Partyfloor noch diverse Motive irgendwie da aufs Textil gebracht. Und dann hat auch irgendwie so eine neben mir, meine so, ja, also ich würde jetzt für meine Schwester auch gerne irgendwie noch was drucken, aber ich bräuchte, also die haben das richtige Motiv, aber ich bräuchte irgendwie grünen Stoff. Kriegt man jetzt hier grünen Stoff? Alles hat zu in Hamburg. Und so, ja, wie viel brauchst du denn? Na ja, soll halt so und so groß sein. Das war schon irgendwie ein relativ großes Ausmachen. So, hm, ja, hast du die mal gefragt, ob sie vielleicht grünen Stoff zufällig da haben? So, und dann so, ja, nee, also, ne, doch, geh mal hin, frag mal, frag mal. Also sind ja auch scheinbar irgendwie so Siebdrucknerz, und zack, irgendwie, sie geht so hin, so ganz schüchtern, fragt so, ja, habt ihr zufällig so grünen Stoff? Und dann so, meinst du vielleicht diesen grünen Stoff? Oder diesen grünen Stoff? Und hat dann so auch hinter dieser kleinen improvisierten Bar Siebdruckwerkstatt, irgendwie, diverse Stoffbahnen noch ausgepackt, und sie war dann so, okay, okay, in dieser Partysituation, neben der Bar, irgendwie. Und einfach so diese Ansage, ja, wieso, fahrt ihr doch einfach mal. Und wo man immer so, diese kleinen Momente jedes Mal, wo man denkt, so der ganz normale Wahnsinn, echt, ey, alles ist möglich.
Jetzt müssten wir ja eigentlich auch noch von HGiT sprechen.
Allerdings.
Wir standen an der besagten Bar, die Huckel ja schon gelobt hat. Und dann schrie da vorne irgendwie auf einmal so ein Irrer rum. Und ich dachte so, oh mein Gott, als war der letzte Abend, ich dachte, oh mein Gott, ey, was haben die hier für ein Booking gemacht? Jetzt ist da ein Wahnsinniger und schreit irgendwie rum beim Auflegen. Im Chat steht schon Hauptschule, Hauptschule, Hauptschule. Ja, und das war dann, keine Ahnung, der Typ ging irgendwie durch die Menge und laberte Mist, aber hochkarätigen Mist.
Und so ribbeldi ribbeldi Psy-Trans-Goha-Deluxe.
Ich habe ein Buch, ich schlage das Buch auf, ich lese die Seite, ich ruf den Chef von Mercedes an.
Das Geile war halt schon Tage davor, ich hab so einen Kollegen, der auch total in der Elektroszene drin ist und auch immer zum Kongress fährt, weil das Kulturprogramm im Clubclub so gut ist, also unter anderem natürlich, aber auch deswegen. Und dann hab ich den so angeschrieben, weil ich ja diese ganzen Elektronik-Artists kenne ja nicht so, und dann meinte ich so, ja, was würdest du dieses Mal so empfehlen? Hab ihm das Programm geschickt und meinte, oh, HGichT, oder wie auch immer die ausspricht, HGichT. HGichT, meine ich so, guck dir die mal an. Also, ist was anderes. Und dann irgendwie hab ich von verschiedenen Nerds gehört, ja, ich hab gehört, die würden bei manchen Auftritten so LSD ins Publikum sprühen, ne? Und dann irgendwann erwische ich so C-Punkt in der Lounge, so auf eine Zigarette, und wir unterhalten uns so ein bisschen, und er war ja auch relativ entspannt und so, und dann sprachen wir auch über HGichT. Und C-Punkt hat ja nun echt schon viel an Party, Clubs und Feierei gesehen, ne? Und C-Punkt meint jetzt mir, ja, das ist so ein Act, den willst du eigentlich nicht auf deiner eigenen Party haben, sondern den willst du bei anderen Leuten auf der Party sehen, weil danach eventuell dein Veranstaltungsort in Ruinen liegt oder so. Und C-Punkt hatte auch ein relativ ernstes Gesicht, und dann dachte ich so, oh, okay, okay, okay, okay. Also wenn so viel Ehrfurcht auch vom Master of Ceremony kommt, Holla die Waldfee, dann war es auch Holla die Waldfee, aber ganz anders, als ich es gedacht hätte. Ich habe auch vorher vorher kein YouTube-Video geguckt und so.
Die YouTube-Videos werden denen auch nicht wirklich gerecht. Also was da passiert ist, das war...
Diese verschallerten Goa-Girls, dieser Typ mit der Gitarre.
Diese Telefonnummer auf der Stirn, und es ging so wahnsinnig immer dadurch, jetzt müsst ihr euch alle hinlegen, bei drei. Es war einfach großartig. Es ist auch seltsam, du mal zu einer ganz anderen Musik exstatisch tanzen zu können. Nein, nicht jetzt hier.
Du musst mal Hauptschule einspielen. Du musst mal ein Gefühl kriegen für den ganzen Kram. Das wäre schon mal ganz wichtig. Das ist auch relativ kurz.
Hoffentlich ist da der Countdown drin.
Das wird auch schon ausreichend verstören, denke ich mal.
Das war ein anderer Sänger, die haben ja immer wechselnde Besetzungen.
Das ist irgendwie Tutor Inchamun, das ist halt der Typ, der da irgendwie auch immer so rum gepostet hat und so. Und dann andere Vogel, weiß nicht ganz genau mit dem Mikrofon. Was man halt verstehen muss ist, die sind nicht doof. Nein, die sind genau das Gegenteil davon. Ich meine, ich hab jetzt mal einen Abend verbracht und mir mal diesen Kanal irgendwie nicht komplett durchgeschaut, aber viel so und gibt es auch hier und da ein paar interessante Interviews. Und wenn du halt mal, auch nur mal einen da mal normal reden hörst, dann weißt du sofort, dass...
Ich hab mit dem Mann, der da immer wahnsinnig durch die Menge ging, nachher noch im Backstage kurz unterhalten. Der hat da auch sehr viele, also er hat verschiedene Wörter gesagt, die waren auch verständlich und so. Und das war, die können schon ganze Sätze sprechen. Die kommen ja auch irgendwie aus so einem Hamburger Kunstschule-Umfeld oder so. Ja, die wissen schon, was sie da machen. Und er hat ja auch von 10 runtergezählt und damit bewiesen. Es ging irgendwie so 10, 9, 8, 7, 6 minus 6, 6 plus, 5 minus 5 und dann war Ende.
Man kann sich das, also was man sich wirklich schwer, was auch ich mir sehr schwer vorstellen konnte, vor dem Congress, und ich war einfach auch, also irgendjemand hat gesagt und das war glaube ich die beste Beschreibung so, HGiT, das ist so ein bisschen wie so ein Autobahnunfall, ja. Das ist zwar eigentlich furchtbar, aber du kannst halt nicht wegsehen. Du statzt da und musstest dir das ganze einfach geben. Warst irgendwie vollkommen eingenommen von diesem Geschehen, wie die alle irgendwie, denn die haben sich ja dann immer auf die Leute gestürzt und wurden dann irgendwie hin und her getragen, dass das funktioniert auf dem Kongress. Da dachte ich mir so, oh wow, dann haben die so, ja, muss man eine stabile Seitenlage einnehmen und alle nehmen sich hin, weißte, der ganze Kongress liegt so irgendwie wie so Würmer übereinander. Es war einfach ein Bild, das war einfach fantastisch, fantastisch. Und da war ich schon so ein bisschen stolz, muss ich sagen. Also, dass der kleine Kongress das jetzt auch noch bringt und irgendwie abfindet. Ich meine, nicht alle kriegten das gewechselt. Es gab auch ein paar Leute, die sind so blöd.
Also ich würde nachher eben trotzdem sagen, die haben den Laden leer gespielt. Also da waren ein paar hundert Leute, die völlig abgegangen sind und die machten auch, das waren auch die feinen Leute, die man noch da haben wollte. Aber ich muss sagen, ich glaube, nach HGich hatte ich dann doch teilweise den Aldo, das ein bisschen leer war. Aber die Leute, die dann noch da waren, die brauchten auch ein bisschen mehr Platz. Insofern war das schon...
Ja ey, also ich war ja die ganze Zeit direkt vor der DJ-Turbine und dann war ja dann Tim auch eine Weile da und so. Also ich war sozusagen mittendrin. Ich habe auch gar nicht mitbekommen, ob da hinten jetzt irgendwie noch Leute sind oder nicht. Aber ja, ich meine, das war wirklich eine krasse Show, muss man einfach neidlos anerkennen. Okay, das ist dann auch dann das Ende der Congress-Abhandlung.
Wir haben noch so viel.
Ihr müsst einfach mal nächstes Mal vorbeikommen. Ihr seht, wir füllen hier zwei Stunden mit Anekdoten und wir könnten noch weiter erzählen, aber es ist ja auch die Freak Show, wir müssen ja mal mehr über...
Was reden? Bingo.
Ja, vielleicht noch so Assorted Stuff.
Okay, wir haben ja sonst auch keine Themen.
Also hier mal was ganz nett ist, und zwar soll das wohl mittelfristig auch noch mal zu den Recordings dazukommen, aber von Michael Kreil, der ja hier... Ich pack das mal in den Chat auch gleich hier, die Ull. Michael Kreil, der auch schon hier schon mal zu Gast war, früher Open Data City, hier unser Statistik, was heißt Statistik, Visualisierungsspezie. Der hat das schon vor einiger Zeit mal, glaube ich, mit Congress-Videos an oder mit Republika-Videos. Was er gemacht hat, ist, er hat sich die ganzen Recordings genommen und durch so eine Scriptwüste durchgejagt mit viel FFmpeg, und hat sich quasi auf die Suche gemacht nach Stills. Also er sucht quasi die Videos nach Stellen ab, wo sich im Bild wenig bis nichts ändert. Und davon macht er dann quasi einen Screenshot mit Timecode und baut das Ganze zu einzelnen Bildern und dann eben auch zu kompletten PDFs zusammen. Mit anderen Worten, hier gibt es für jeden Vortrag, wenn man auf die URL geht, dann sieht man halt den Kongressplan, und dann sieht man eben für jeden einzelnen Vortrag automatisch generierte Slides. Das heißt, man lädt sich einfach hier, ich hab jetzt hier mal Dieselgate, laden wir mal das passende PDF dazu runter und schwuppdiwupp, schon kriegt man hier in HD-Auflösung Upsala, immer wenn sich quasi was geändert hat in dem Talk, gibt es sozusagen fertige Slides. Das coole daran ist natürlich, du bist jetzt nicht davon abhängig, dass die Vortragenden fertige Slides als PDF vorher auf einem USB-Stick, wo denn ein Computer, den da irgendjemand einsammeln muss und richtig einsortieren muss und so weiter, es fällt halt einfach raus und es ist vor allem auch genau so, wie es eben präsentiert wurde. Und das ist super praktisch, weil, wenn man eben das PDF hat, zusätzlich zu einem Talk, den man schaut, dann hat man immer so diesen Vorteil, dass man quasi vor, zurück, so immer so den letzten Slide, obwohl er schon wieder beim nächsten ist, aber dann kann man sich diese Tabelle nochmal anschauen, ohne jetzt immer wieder anhalten und zurückspulen zu müssen. Also es macht einfach für eine sehr viel umfassendere Recording-Experience, wie man heutzutage so schön sagt.
Wenn man jetzt noch richtig cool ist, lässt man den direkt durch irgendeinen OCR-Teil durchlaufen, packt ihn in die PFs unten drunter, damit man sie noch schön durchsuchen kann.
Ja, genau.
Next Step.
Das wäre in der Tat eine mögliche Verbesserung.
Obwohl, vielleicht hat er das schon drin. Kannst du was delektieren in dem Ding? Kannst du, wo da Mengen von Text stehen? Kannst du die irgendwie? Weißt du, wie die ScanSaps machen? Dass du das so transparent darunter legst, dass man aber jetzt, wie gesagt, danach suchen kann und eben auch Sachen rauscopy and wasteen kann.
Genau. Hier sieht man es jetzt auch gerade, wo ich hier mal so rumklicke. Was ich nicht so eine kluge Idee hielt, war das in diesem Combined View. Man hat ja hier immer so diesen DIN A4 Ausschnitt des Speakers und dann den Slide hier auf 80% Größe und dann ist hier unten noch dieses 32C3-Ding aber leider in dieser animierten Variante. Und wenn man sich in Ruhe auf diesen Talk konzentrieren will, hat man in diesem View halt immer wieder diese Unruhe.
Ja, aber ich nehme, da musst du dich jetzt mal bei jemand anders beschweren. Dieses App hat das Vogue gemacht.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine Frage des Videocompositing.
Aber immerhin, das scheint hier die kralte Erkennungslogik, der scheint dir egal zu sein. Die lässt auch den Talking Head rechts kalt. Sondern wahrscheinlich guckt die, ob nur größere Teile des Bildes nicht ändern.
Also der hat das schon ziemlich gut ausgerichtet.
Die Grundidee ist vermutlich gar nicht so schwer. Du musst da vielleicht gar nicht rangehen, indem du selber das Bild analysierst. Ich glaube, das reicht schon aus, wenn du einfach anguckst, wie die bereits komprimiert, der bereits komprimierte Datenstrom, wie groß der ist, weil je weniger sich in dem Bild ändert, desto kleiner ist es. Wenn du sozusagen nur ein Talking Head unten rechts in der Ecke hast, dann hast du nur ein paar Kilowits, die da verbraucht werden. Und wenn du halt große Änderungen, Bildwechsel hast oder so was, dann geht das halt in die Megawitze hoch. Aber egal, wir können den Michael ja mal fragen, wie er das macht. Aber finde ich gut gemacht, fällt mir sehr gut.
Er hat auch meine Slide-Decks größtenteils korrekt reversed hier. Das kann man so gelten lassen. Ich habe jetzt einen Backup in der Cloud. Das ist auch gut.
Ja.
Churi? Das war auch eine von unseren Folien. Churi heißt ja nicht hier, das Ding, das drauf gelandet ist.
Ja, aber der Klotz da, das fliegende Ding.
Hatte der einen Namen?
Nicht viele. Viele hieß das Ding, das drauf gelandet ist. Aber der Komet heißt Churi. Oder wie kannst du den kompletten Namen richtig aussprechen?
67P. Chur, Monoff, Gerasimenko.
Da sind wir drauf gelandet mit der Feridas. Auf dem Folien.
In welchen Folien?
Und kannst du noch mit der Feridas reden?
Welcher Talk war denn das jetzt?
Das ist das Opening gewesen.
Achso, im Opening war das.
Diese Opening-Nummer ist inzwischen so ein bisschen euer Familienbusiness, ne? So gesehen.
Was meinst du mit welchen? Lass mir das. Letztes Jahr war in meinem Camp ja Huckel. Und Huckel und ich sind weder Verwandt noch Verschwäger.
Aber Huckel war nicht alleine.
Ja, das war, da habe ich nichts mehr zu tun. Also man kann das ja nur, also das mit dem Opening, das geht ja, man denkt dann eben so, da freue ich mich, aber das ist eine große Ehre und so. Und dann irgendwann so eine Woche vorher merkt man dann auf einmal, dass man irgendwie viel mehr Wasser trinken muss, wenn man die ganze Zeit schwitzt und irgendwie auch gar nicht mehr so gerne ist und irgendwie mit dem Schlafen funktioniert auch nicht mehr. Und dann denkt man irgendwann so, scheiße, warst du aufgeregt?
Warum nur?
Ich glaube, ich bin eigentlich jetzt so Lampenfieber oder so was, hatte ich mich jetzt eigentlich für immun gehalten, aber so ein Opening-Event von einer Ccc-Veranstaltung ist dann schon...
Juna meinte, du wärst nervöser gewesen als wir. Beide zusammen. Aber das hat sie wahrscheinlich auch nur gesagt, weil du beim Camp so die ganze Zeit, naja, kommt ihr.
Ich kann das mal nicht so anheben. Könnte ja nichts falsch machen. Dann hast du so einen Onkel Tiffen, der dann so väterlich seine Hand auf deine Schulter legt und sagt, pass mal auf, das ist folgendermaßen. Da sitzen 3000 Leute mit offenen Augen und sagen, kann ich jetzt kommen? Und du musst einfach nur dazu beitragen, dass sie sich freuen und kommen können. Und wenn du das versaust, dann ist das scheiße. Aber solange du denen das nicht versaust, das habe ich nicht gesagt. So ungefähr hat es mir das gesagt. Und dann habe ich schon wieder was getrunken.
Ich hatte ein anderes Beispiel gebracht, wo wirklich alles falsch lief. Dein Ansatz war sehr weit von entfernt. Da hatte ich nicht nur die Spur eines Bedenkens, dass das schon ordentlich über die Bühne gehen würde.
So habe ich dann auch Roland und Friederik das Video aus dem Rippen geleiert. Wenn danach alles schief gehen würde, wäre dieses Video immerhin etwas...
Das Hauptproblem ist ja, dass man eigentlich... Du hast ja auch relativ viel Mühe da reingesteckt, das zu skripten. Das war ja ein sehr minutiös geplantes Ding. Das ist an sich auch gar kein Problem, das zu machen. Man hat bloß nur einen Schuss, weil man keine Möglichkeit hat, das in dieser Halle vorher mal in Ruhe durchzutesten mit einer Crew, wie man das sonst auf Veranstaltungen natürlich tun würde.
Ich meine, das ist auch einfach nur Nervosität. Karina und ich, da die ganze Zeit auf unsere Karten gucken. Wir konnten das seit einer Woche auswählen. Wir haben eine Woche lang nichts anderes gemacht. Eine Woche? Keine Ahnung, ein paar Tage vorher. Aber auf jeden Fall diese Bühne im...
Sag dir jetzt nicht, weil ich meinen 32C3 Talk gemacht habe.
Ich weiß, wann du den gemacht hast. Das Problem mit dieser Bühne in Saal 1 ist, dieser Saal 1 beinhaltet zwar 3000 Sitzplätze, der beinhaltet aber auch Atemluft für mindestens 12.000 Leute, weil der so hoch ist. Da ist einfach unglaublich viel Luft in diesem Saal, die bewegt werden will. Und entsprechend stehst du eigentlich relativ alleine auf diesem verfluchten Fußballfeld, was da Bühne heißt. Und kriegst relativ wenig Rückmeldungen so akustisch von dem Menschen, der da ist. Also wenn die dann lachen, dann hörst du so ein leises und wenn die laut applaudieren, dann hörst du das auch. Aber man fühlt sich einfach da so ein bisschen sehr allein. Wird auch stark angestrahlt von, weiß nicht, wie viel Kilowatt Licht. Und siehst dann, wenn der Raum abgedunkelt ist, siehst du auch nicht weit. Und dann bist du halt irgendwie auf einer Bühne, allein auf weiter Flur. Ich weiß, da hinten im Dunkeln sind relativ viele Leute, ab und zu hört man die auch mal mit den Füßen scharren. Aber diese Bühne ist relativ überwältigend. Zumindest empfinde ich das so. Und ich habe mich ja auch bisher da gezielt nie alleine draufgetraut. Also ich bin Vorträge immer schön, sei g oder so. Und dann halt mal Ccc Jahresrückblick in Begleitung, wo ich wusste, wenn vier ausfallen, haben wir immer noch eine Person mindestens, die weiterreden kann.
Ich finde ja solche Räume geil.
Ja, also das ist schon ein super Raum, aber...
It's intimidating.
Der ist schon... Und ich habe das auch bei einigen wenigen Vortragenden auch gesehen, dass der...
Du bist ja immer noch ganz eingeschüchtert, aber das ist schon vorbei. Nein, aber das ist... Es ist vorbei.
Scheiße, zwei Wochen Psychotherapie, der Arsch.
Oh, jetzt beschweren sich die Leute über Themenarmut. Ja, dann seht ihr mal, wie themenarm mein Gehirn seit Monaten ist. Ich denke nur noch an diesen Raum.
Denkst nur noch an diesen Podcast.
Wir müssen wieder mehr über Max reden.
Ja, wir müssen vor allem diesen 32C3 dann auch mal gecovert haben und das muss halt jetzt sein. Und danach ist er auch gut. Also in der nächsten Sendung gibts das halt nicht mehr.
Und nach dem Kongress ist ja vor dem Kongress.
Genau.
Ah, nein, doch, Moment, eins noch, ganz schnell. Dieses Comic, was du gepostet hast von diesem Typ, der seinen 32C3 illustriert hat, kannst du mal noch diesen Link da reinhauen in den Chat.
Beatle-Bum ja ganz großartig.
Nein, was, wie?
Beatle-Bum sagt ja gar nichts, doch, bestimmt.
Vielleicht vom Sehen?
Ja, vom Sehen vor allem.
Das ist, glaube ich, nicht die Seite.
Nee, das ist, warte mal.
Jetzt machen wir mal Punkt. Ah nee, Bum Going Places ist das, glaube ich, oder?
Block beatlebum.de, da wollte ich hin, ja. Genau, hier der 32C3 Recap. Das ist grandios. Das ist natürlich jetzt schwer zu beschreiben, aber...
Klickt da mal in die Show-Notes.
Ich muss... Ich ärgere mich so ein bisschen, dass ich ihn nicht getroffen habe. Das ist ja wohl nicht das erste Mal auf dem Kongress. Das war mir, ehrlich gesagt, bisher noch nicht so ganz klar. Er macht ja überhaupt super Comics. Aber diese Storys, wie irgendwie hier seine Freundin das erste Mal auf dem Kongress ist und sonst haben sie diese ganzen Welten dort so erlebt. Und irgendwie diese ganze Erschöpfung und den ganzen Wahnsinn, was man alles gelernt hat, Konferenztipps und alles Mögliche. Das ist einfach Wahrheit. 32C3 Tipps und Tricks, der beste Platz, Saal 6 ganz hinten rechts, Brüstung zum Arm ablegen, Licht direkt von oben, freies Blickfeld, fancy Empore, Tisch, eigene Steckdose, Stuhl mit Armlehne, minimaler Weg zum Ausgang und damit Marthe nachschuben. Das ist der Königsplatz. Okay, das müsst ihr euch mal angucken. Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr schön. Grüße an den Hesse-Nummer. Ja, den Hesse-Nummer. Richtig.
Keine Klarnamen.
Doch.
Johannes Kretschmer.
Genau.
Steht auf der Webseite.
Ich würde gerne noch ein, zwei Dinge erwähnen, was ja eigentlich bei dem Kongress das Bezaubernde ist. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie viel über, sag ich mal, geplante und dargebotene Entertainment gesprochen. Irgendwie Sendezentrum, Vorträge, Lounge oder so. Aber was ich eigentlich immer bei den Ccc-Veranstaltungen am beeindruckendsten finde, ist das, was dann dort entsteht. Ich weiß, Tim, eine Toilettenparty war auch sehr beeindruckend. Aber was ich eigentlich so finde, wie sich so Assemblies dann entwickeln und was die Leute da alles an Sachen anschleppen. Und ich hab da ein Chaos-Patenkind getroffen, kennengelernt. Der war ein bisschen älter als ich. Und hatte aber, wenn du mal hier unter Strand Biest auf den zweiten Link klickst, das fand ich echt geil. Das ist ein Roboter, der gehen kann.
Das ist ein Nachbau von diesen Stranddingern.
Das ist also ein gar nicht so komplexes System, was irgendwie Drehbewegung umsetzt in so ein etwas komplexeres Gelenksystem, was dann wiederum Füße antreibt. Der hat da einen sechsbeinigen Roboter, der letztendlich einfach rechts und links durch einen... Tim, bleib doch mal ruhig bei dem Video, das ich da jetzt gerade hatte, über den sprechen wir ja auch gerade. Der läuft, dieser Roboter. Die Arduino-Steuerung ist dafür eigentlich relativ einfach, weil du nur rechts oder links drehen musst. Ist das nicht geil? Er kann auf der Stelle drehen mit seiner G-Bewegung und kann halt nach vorne gehen. Dann hatte er sich noch verschiedene Erweiterungen gebaut, wie zum Beispiel ein Strand-Beast, das vorne eine Kamera dran hat und immer auf das rote Objekt zugeht. Wenn es kein rotes Objekt sieht, sucht es ein rotes Objekt. Was ziemlich beängstigend ist, wenn das Ding da auf einmal irgendwie so rumschaut. Die Code-Base ist dann doch simpler, als man meint. Das Ding fand ich echt geil. Das war jetzt mal jemand, der zu Hause sitzt, mal ins Fab Lab geht, sich mal eben so Dinge bastelt und dann irgendwie ernsthaft noch sich nicht sicher war, ob er auf dem Hacker-Congress unter den richtigen Leuten ist und sich bei den Chaos-Party anmeldet, um einen leichteren Einstieg zu finden. Und dann sich plötzlich in der Situation wiederfindet, dass er da einfach mal einen der coolsten Roboter am Platz hat und aus den Gesprächen nicht mehr rauskommt, weil alle von diesem Ding begeistert sind. Das fand ich echt ein sehr cooles Teil. Das möchte ich auch bauen.
Man muss mal kurz das auf das Original verweisen. Also Strand-Base, das ist, glaube ich, aus Holland. Eben von diesem Theo Jansen, so ein Künstler, der die Dinge halt entworfen hat. Und die sind halt explizit dafür gemacht, am Strand zu stehen und mit dem Strandwind sich automatisch zu bewegen. Und der hat halt da, hier gibt es einen kleinen Evolution-Film, wo das irgendwie gezeigt wird, wie sich das Ding so über die Zeit weiterentwickelt hat. Der hat das halt wirklich zur Perfektion getrieben, bis er wirklich so riesige Monstren da aus Holz gebaut hat, die einfach magisch nur vom Wind über den Strand getrieben werden. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Das ist hier aber noch nicht die Variante, die ich gerade suche. Ich glaube, das hier ist eher schon das Ding. Das ist unglaublich faszinierend. Das ist eine Metallvariante, da gibt es ein Holz, also alles Mögliche. Das ist natürlich eine sehr coole Idee, so etwas auf dem Kongress nachzubauen. Und dann noch auch wie so Steuerbar. Fantastisch. Was lasst ihr?
Ich lese gerade im Chat, Linus und Tim sind das neue Delling und Netzer. Solange ich Netzer sein darf, ist mir das alles recht. Auf jeden Fall finde ich diese Roboter cool, Tim. Und ich möchte auch so einen haben. Aber eigentlich nicht haben, sondern bauen. Genau, diese Strandbeste sind eben angetrieben vom Wind und der war angetrieben von einem Akku. Und dann mit Fernbedienung und so. Und das ist alles gar nicht so schwierig. Du warst schon so ein Sechsbeiniger Roboter. Stell dir mal vor, wenn das die Zukunft ist. Und dann kommen die hier die Straßen lang und nehmen uns die Arbeitsplätze weg.
So, wir hätten hier noch zum Thema Medienecho was reingeschrieben. Ist das noch erwähnenswert?
Ja, Medienecho war wie immer großartig. Es gab nur irgendwie so einen Artikel auf Spiegel Online, weil wir ja immer davon sprechen, dass eigentlich allen Menschen sich die Veranstaltung erschließt, wenn sie dort sind. Es gab aber einen Redakteur bei Spiegel Online, dem hat sich die Veranstaltung nicht erschlossen. Und dummerweise bin wahrscheinlich ich schuld, weil ich mit ihm das Gespräch geführt habe als Vertreter des Ccc und so. Und der hat dann irgendwie, was ich sehr erstaunlich fand, sich dann in einem Artikel darüber beschwert, dass man erwarten, also er schreibt, wird hier tatsächlich vier Tage über Bürgerrechte und Freiheit gestritten? Nein. Am Ende geht es um etwas ganz anderes. Um Politik geht es hier irgendwie gar nicht. Worum denn dann? Natürlich gibt es auch Vorträge zum NSA-Ausschuss, aber vor allem geht es um Technik. Es ist ein Hacker-Kongress. Dann beschwert er sich, dass sich die Menschen über Technik reden. Und dann erwartet er Streit. Ich habe lange überlegt, warum das so ist, bis ich dann irgendwann verstanden habe, natürlich, Spiegel Online, die haben einfach drei Jahre lang die Piratenpartei in Grund und Boden geschrieben. Natürlich erwartet der, dass sich da Menschen streiten. Aber ich meine, bei dieser Veranstaltung streiten sich doch jetzt keine Menschen über Grund, Bürgerrechte und Freiheit. Das fand ich irgendwie sehr komisch. Das war wirklich sehr interessant, dieser Artikel, um mal zu sehen, wie die Veranstaltung auf jemanden wirkt, dem sie sich nicht erschließt. In der Frage der Geflüchteten fällt Ihnen nichts anderes ein, als zu sagen, Internetzugang ist ein Menschenrecht, in Klammern, was Freifunkaktivisten ja versuchen, durchzusetzen mit unterschiedlichem Erfolg. Ich wurde korrigiert, ich habe in der Opening-Ceremonie von über 100 Unterkünften für Geflüchtete gesprochen. Es sind über 200, wo freiwillige Aktivisten hingehen und da WLAN-Hindengeln auf eigene Kosten, auf eigene Zeit und da die Menschen versorgen. Ihm fällt da nichts mehr zu ein, als das in Klammern zu setzen und zu sagen, den Hackern fällt nichts ein. Das fand ich echt mal interessant. Also ich bin enorm beeindruckt von diesen Freifunk-Sachen und von dieser Hilfe, die da irgendwie in kürzester Zeit überall in Deutschland selbst organisiert von kleinen Gruppen aus dem Boden schießt. Und dieser Mann ist enttäuscht. Vielleicht sollten wir uns an den halten.
Das hängt aber mit der allgemeinen Auffassung in Deutschland zusammen. Ich glaube, dass das für das, was das Internet gut ist. Wenn ihr sagt, wir bringen den Geflüchteten, hier gibt es Freiwillige, die machen den Fernsehen, dass sie endlich RTL 2 gucken können, oder wer wird Millionär? Das wird ihm klar, wie wichtig das ist.
Ich hätte erwartet, weil ihr für Spiegel online schreibt, dass er das mit dem Online schon versteht. Wahrscheinlich ist er einfach nur sauer, weil wir den natürlich auch direkt Adblocker mitliefern.
Du hättest halt sagen müssen, Freifunk ermöglicht ist, allen Geflüchteten Spiegel online zu lesen.
Genau. Den Artikel empfehle ich, einfach mal um, wenn man sich jetzt hier von uns zweieinhalb Stunden die Ohren halt blutig labern lassen, wie geil der Kongress ist, hier ist mal jemand, der das nicht so sieht. Also, irgendwie annähernd 40 Polit-Talks im Programm, aber das ist natürlich keine politische Veranstaltung, weil man da nicht streitet.
Kriegen wir uns jetzt nicht weiter drüber auf.
Nee, ich rede mich da nicht drüber auf, ich empfehle das. Ich empfehle das.
Wir haben nämlich glaube ich auch hier noch einen Talk vergessen zu erwähnen. Den Clemens vielleicht gesehen haben könnte. Ich weiß nicht, hast du überhaupt einen gesehen?
Hab ich doch schon erzählt, die ich gesehen habe, oder welche von denen.
Hast du auch den mit dem Volti? Den hatten wir nämlich noch gar nicht, weil da war ja noch so zwei Kurs.
Den Talk wollte ich noch sehen, den habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Den habe ich noch nicht zugekommen.
Dann vielleicht nächstes Mal.
Da hatten die Leute natürlich auch wieder drum. Ist klar, neue Infrastruktur zum Spielen.
Gut, dann kommen wir vielleicht auf einen anderen Aspekt. Und zwar die Sache mit der Doku. Wer auf dem Camp war, dürfte schon mitbekommen haben, dass da so ein eifriges Kamerateam unterwegs war. Und die waren auch diesmal auf dem Kongress. So wie ich das mitbekommen habe, haben die sich auch bis zur letzten Erschöpfung auf dieser Veranstaltung aufgehalten. Solange es irgendwie ging, immer mit schwere Kamera unterwegs und immer auch betulicht darauf bedacht, die doch etwas komplexen Foto- und Fotografie- und Befilmungsregeln des Kongresses auch möglichst zu beachten. Was dahinter steht, ist ein Doku-Film-Team um Sandra Torstel, die das ganz professionell betreibt und die vorhat, einen Doku-Film zu machen über dieses ganze Ccc-Eventgeschehen mit einem großen Schwerpunkt wahrscheinlich auf dem Camp und mit einem sicherlich nicht zu verachtenden weiteren Schwerpunkt auf dem Kongress, so wie das dann eben die Story dann letzten Endes miteinander verknüpft, die da am Ende erzählt werden soll. Der Film soll Ende dieses Jahres dann irgendwann auch mal fertig werden. Bis dahin ist noch ein langer Weg zu gehen. Also jetzt haben sie irgendwie erstmal tonnenweise Material und das muss ja alles erstmal gesichtet werden, das muss dann irgendwann mal geschnitten werden und am Ende muss es dann eben auch eine anspruchsvolle Geschichte erzählen. Und wie wir alle wissen, ist das mit der Finanzierung von solchen Mammut-Projekten auch nicht so einfach. Und deswegen hat sie eine Crowdfunding-Kampagne gestartet. Die hatte das ja auch im Jahresrückblick schon drin und hatte auch den Trailer gezeigt, der auf Vimeo liegt und der auch eingebettet ist auf der Indiegogo-Seite, wo diese Crowdfunding-Kampagne läuft. Jetzt habe ich gar nicht hier die URL in meiner Liste. Die hole ich mal geschwind hervor. Ja, und was hat es jetzt damit auf sich? Also, ich will nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, aber im Kern ist das eben der Versuch, diese Doku einerseits so zu finanzieren, wie man das eben braucht, also mit relativ hohem zeitlichen Aufwand und mit vielen Leuten, die halt an sowas mitarbeiten. Und im Idealfall passiert dann auch was mit diesem Film, was normalerweise nicht passiert, dass der nämlich auch frei kopierbar ist, oder mit anderen Worten unter so einer kompatiblen Creative Commons Lizenz veröffentlicht wird. Und darum geht es im Wesentlichen eigentlich bei dieser Crowdfunding-Kampagne. Die ist aber jetzt, weil Crowdfunding-Kampagnen heutzutage immer noch nicht sehr viel inhärente Intelligenz abbilden, habe ich manchmal so den Eindruck, vielleicht etwas schwer zu verstehen, weil man da halt so mehrere Phasen, also man kennt so eine Plattform, wo man so mehrere Phasen zum Beispiel ordentlich abbilden kann. Bisher ist das irgendwie nicht der Fall. Also vielleicht gibt es irgendeine, die das kann.
Ich habe nur geschmutzelt wegen dieser Formulierungen, die du aber sehr gut beschreibt.
Also kurz gesagt, es gibt hier im Wesentlichen eigentlich zwei Ziele. Das Komische ist, wenn man jetzt auf diese Seite geht, dass da so von drei Zielen die Rede ist. Das Erste ist im Prinzip, hängt mit dem Zweiten zusammen. Und das ist so das Aufbringen des Mindestbetrages, den man selber einbringen muss, wenn man möchte, dass der Rest so in der Größenordnung von 80% von einer Filmförderung getragen wird. Das Problem ist mit diesen Filmförderungen, dass die extrem bekloppte Auflagen machen, auf alles Mögliche im Übrigen, auch was so Vermarktungsdetail betrifft und so, das überblickliche, selber alles nur, sehr eingeschränkt. Auf jeden Fall, kurz gesagt, wenn man aber so eine Filmförderung bezieht, dann ist es irgendwie kaum bis unmöglich, so einen Film einfach ins Netz zu packen, um zu sagen, hier schaut euch das an.
Die wollen vielleicht am Ende sogar ihr Geld wieder haben.
Die wollen, ja, die wollen ihr Geld wieder haben im Erfolgsfall. Also diese Förderungen sind halt so angelegt, muss dann so Einnahmen generieren und wenn dann halt wirklich so viel Kohle erstmal reinkommt bei irgendwelchen Film-Aufführungen etc., was bei den wenigsten in der Falle ist, kann natürlich sein, dass sie mal was fördern, was jetzt hier so kein Ohrhasentisch weigermäßig total durch die Decke geht und alle müssen sich das angucken, dann kommen dann so ein paar Millionen rein, dann wird halt diese Filmförderung wieder zurückgezahlt und alles andere, was darüber hinausgeht, das bleibt dann halt bei dir. Aber mit so einem Crowdfunding-Modell ist diese Welt nur sehr begrenzt zu verbinden. Und jetzt ist es so, dass jetzt kurz, ich glaube, dass dieses Ziel hatte sich jetzt irgendwie auf dem Kongress auch noch nicht so richtig rumgesprochen. Leute haben zwar gemerkt, da ist ja irgendwie eine Doku, und das ist irgendwie ganz nett und die brauchen irgendwie Unterstützung, aber das Ding ist, hier wollen wir eigentlich nur eine Doku auf Kino-Level über Camp und Kongress und damit im Prinzip die ganze Chaos-Eventkultur machen lassen. Oder, also, will die Sandra und ihr Team machen, und wir finden das toll, dass das jemand macht. Und am Ende ist es aber trotzdem frei verfügbar. Und dazu brauchen wir aber im Prinzip die komplette Kohle ohne diese Absicherung durch die Filmförderung. Und ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass das gelingen kann. Also ich hab da auf jeden Fall schon mal Kohle reingeschmissen.
Man braucht sich ja nur den Trailer anzuschauen, um zu sehen, dass das halt echt ein geiler Film wird. Die Sandra kann ja auch echt inzwischen ein Lied von singen, wie sie irgendwie ankam und ihr eigentlich nichts als arg wohnen entgegenschlug, übrigens auch von mir. Sie inzwischen halt, weiß nicht, sich über den Congress bewegt. Viele sie schon kennen und sie halt zu den wenigen gehört, die mit ihrer Kamera nicht irgendwie verscheucht und beschimpft werden, sondern wo die Leute von weitem winken, so hier, guck mal, möchtest du das vielleicht filmen? Nee, ich bin grad auf dem Milch, ja, aber komm doch jetzt noch mal schnell hier. Und ja, sie ist hier halt in diesem Trailer, den man da sieht, einfach auch super gelungen, diese Veranstaltung einzufangen. Was ich eigentlich irgendwie immer für unmöglich gehalten habe, zumindest wenn ich versucht habe, mal ein Foto zu machen oder so. Und man schaut das Ding halt an und sagt, ja, es braucht noch nicht viel mehr zu sagen. Und sie hat halt irgendwie den Blick dafür, was man auch von diesen Veranstaltungen erinnert und was ihren Zauber irgendwie ausmacht. Und wir müssen das im Prinzip machen, dass wir das irgendwie hinkriegen, dass wir da einen schönen Film daraus kriegen, der Ccc lizensiert ist. Einfach auch, weil unsere Gehirne ja irgendwann dann auch abbauen. Dann brauchen wir halt so einen Film, um unsere Erinnerungen aufzufrischen.
Und warum finanziert der Ccc das nicht auch zu großen Teilen einfach gleich mit?
Weil es ein bisschen hohe Rechnung ist, die sie da aufstellt.
Die Rechnung ist angemessen, aber es handelt sich absolut um einen nennenswerten Betrag.
Aber ich meine jetzt hier bei dieser Kampagne zumindest.
Also wir haben ja, naja, ich kann jetzt keine Aussage darüber treffen, weil ich nicht weiß, inwiefern das schon eine Diskussion ist oder auch stattfinden wird, ob jetzt irgendwie der Club selber da auch nochmal irgendwas mit rein fandet. Da haben sich schon so die ein oder anderen Organisationen und Netzgranten haben sich da irgendwie auch schon eingeklickt. Hier so Internet Archive und so weiter. Also da ist Interesse entsteht auch gerade. Wir haben ja früher auch selber Dokus machen lassen. Vom Congress hatten wir das von den ersten drei Camps, glaube ich sogar mit Kyriad. Das waren ja auch schöne Sachen, aber es waren halt jetzt keine Full-Length-Feature-Filme, die dabei rausgekommen sind, sondern es waren halt so fünf Minuten, zehn Minuten. Ich weiß nicht, beim zweiten Camp war das Ding irgendwie ein bisschen länger, aber halt auch eher so ein bisschen in die Länge gezogen, indem einfach mehr Raw-Footage sozusagen freigab. Mehr Ingo, oder? Also nochmal eine andere Erzählform. Ich fand die Videos auch super von ihr. Sie ist ja auch eine tolle Geschichtenerzählerin. Aber das ist halt hier nochmal so auf einem anderen Level. Und von daher wirft das natürlich ganz andere Kosten auf, wenn jetzt hier irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre an so einem Ding gearbeitet wird. Und dann Cutter und was weiß ich, was das halt alles noch so für Sachen nach sich zieht. Ja, so. Sehr viel mehr kann man jetzt glaube ich auch erstmal nicht dazu sagen.
Entzieht der Freak Show das Kapital und werft das hier hin.
Arbeitet mehr.
Genau, arbeitet mehr.
Nehmt noch einen Job an und vom zusätzlichen Geld, was ihr dann verdient.
Get a job, get a haircut, funnest movie.
Bei McDonalds stellen sie immer jemanden ein.
Das kann man keinen empfehlen.
Jetzt müssen wir eigentlich, wenn wir schon so bei Videokram sind, mal, ich weiß gar nicht, hattet ihr in der Freak Show auch über die Ccc Tv App gesprochen oder habe ich damit einfach nur jetzt die letzten Wochen immer den Tim im Logbuch geärgert?
Wir haben das so ein bisschen stiefmütterlich zumindest behandelt. Also ich glaube, gefallen ist das Thema zumindest hier in der Vorbereitung, aber wir sind nicht so direkt darauf eingegangen, weil sonst müssten wir ja... Ja, also ich glaube, wir haben es nicht so ausführlich, zumindest war ich nicht da dann. Also so richtig ausführlich haben wir es glaube ich nicht durchgepaut, wie es eigentlich angemessen wäre.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Bei mir überlagert sich das immer mit Lockbruch. Deswegen kann ich das jetzt gerade nicht so genau zuordnen. Aber wir können ja mal kurz die Apple TV App Saga noch mal kurz zusammenfassen. So, was bisher geschah. Im Prinzip müssen wir jetzt auch von vornherein mal klarstellen, es gibt jetzt mittlerweile zwei Apps, die man hier sehr wohl auseinanderhalten muss. Das eine ist im Prinzip die Evolution der schon länger existierenden App von Toto, der ja auch schon mal in der Freak Show war. Da haben wir, glaube ich, auch über die App als solche geredet. Das ist halt sozusagen immer die App, die zu den Events rauskommt mit dem Fahrplan, Schedule, wo es vor allem darum geht, auf dem Event einen Tool zu haben, auf dem Smartphone, mit dem man eben sehen kann, was in den nächsten Talks Notifications bekommen, seine Favoriten klicken kann etc. Und in dem Moment, wo die Recordings verfügbar sind, auch die sich dann eben direkt über die App anschauen kann. Das zweite Projekt ist halt eine neue App, die jetzt direkt aus dem Ccc Frankfurt heraus neu entwickelt wurde, als es halt klar war, dass man auf diesen neuen Apple TV Apps machen kann. Dann wurde halt so ein einfaches App-Konzept gemacht, wo man halt einfach im Prinzip so ein Video-Browser hat für Media ccc.de. Also da geht es primär und vor allem um die Recordings. Und die wurde halt von Apple zunächst einmal nicht im App-Store aufgenommen, also wurde abgelehnt.
Also genau, die App liest im Prinzip den Content ein, der auf Media ccc.de zur Verfügung steht. Der ist in einem maschinenlesbaren Format. Und diese App macht nichts anderes, als sich die Inhalte zu nehmen und sie dann eben auf dem Apple-TV abzuspielen. Das ist wahrscheinlich der einzig sinnvolle Anwendungszweck für eines dieser neuen Apple-TVs, wie es jetzt hier steht. Und ja, das ist echt geil.
Man kann da auch Crossy Road drauf spielen.
Genau, also das ist der einzige sinnvolle Anwendungszweck, der jetzt halt so eine Media Ccc App.
Und im Prinzip vergleichbar mit der YouTube-App.
So, und nun begab es sich, dass das Team diese App dann, Apple, andiente. Und der Review-Prozess seinen Lauf nahm. Und dann dort der, wie nennt man die? Bergwerk App Store, Bergwerk Zwerg oder sowas. Dann irgendwie sagte, aha, Moment mal, das ist doch hier mit Hacking. Und Hacking is not allowed in the Netherlands. Und dann hat er eben gesehen, dass es da acht Vorträge gab, acht in der Geschichte von, ich weiß nicht, wann die Congress-Recordings anfangen. Achtzehn oder sowas, C3?
Ja, die sind nicht so vollständig, aber im Prinzip, glaube ich, haben die jetzt gerade in letzter Zeit nochmal sehr viel alte Kram nachgepflegt. Das geht bis zum ersten Camp.
Genau, also es gibt da durchaus ein Reichtum an Inhalten, den Media CCC dort bereitstellt. Und er fand dann eben, Moment mal, hier ist ja ein Vortrag mit dem Titel Jailbreak, eine Einführung aus dem Jahr, weiß ich nicht, 2000, hast du nicht gesehen, aus dem Geburtsjahr des iPhones oder so? Nee, 2014, doch gar nicht so alt. Und es gibt einen Talk über Social Engineering und Industrie-Spionage. Und einen Talk, wie man ein Kryptovirus für Symphony 2-Applikationen schreibt. Und einen Talk über Exportrestriktionen, Game Hacking und Reverse Engineering, Hacking von medizinischen Geräten, Bluetooth-Hacking, Hardware-Angriffe auf bestimmte Chips. Und das geht ja gar nicht, weil ja die Guidelines von Apple sagen, eure Apps, die ihr hier bei uns verkauft, von denen wir 30 Prozent abkriegen, die befähigen bitte andere Menschen nicht, Apple-Produkte zu hängen. Das war der Auszug der AGB Papyrus-Rolle, auf den sie sich bezogen. Und dann eben sagten sie, mit diesen acht Talks kommt ihr nicht in unseren schönen Apple-TV-Store, wo ihr eure App noch dazu kostenlos andienen möchtet. Und damit war die App dann raus aus dem Rennen. Und es begann ein längerer Diskussionsprozess zwischen den Entwicklern und Apple. Gleichzeitig hat Toto dann jetzt seine Funktion in der iOS- und inzwischen auch TVOS-App hinzugefügt, hat aber jeweils zum Zeitpunkt des Reviews dafür gesorgt, dass einfach nur ein Video vorhanden war. Was eine ebenfalls sehr elegante Lösung ist, diesen Review-Prozess da irgendwie zu um, oder Probleme in dem Review-Prozess proaktiv aus dem Weg zu räumen. Und jetzt hatten wir aber nun mal das Problem, dass jetzt hier zwei Institutionen von weltweiten Ruhm gegenüberstehen. Einerseits natürlich der CCC und andererseits eben... Und jetzt konnte Apple natürlich irgendwie, in diesem Kampf David gegen Goliath, wollte Apple dann jetzt natürlich auch nicht unterliegen und hat dann auf Stur geschaltet. Und jetzt standen halt irgendwie die Zeichen ungünstig. Und es ist ein schönes Beispiel eben für die ja dann doch sehr wirre Willkür, die in diesem App-Store-Review-Prozess stattfindet.
Nein.
Ja, doch.
Jetzt bin ich fürs Bingo gemacht.
Genau, und die Debatten gingen hin und her und jetzt haben schließlich, hat sich schließlich das Team von Ccc Tv dazu entschieden, diese acht Talks tatsächlich aus ihrer App zu entfernen. Das heißt, in der App ist jetzt gehardcoded, da wo dieser Talk ist. Blende bitte ein schönes altes Finder-Symbol ein. Ist das oder? Das ist doch irgendwie so ein altes Mac OS 9 Symbol oder nicht? Tim, du hast das doch noch benutzt, Mac OS 9.
Achso, das ist der alte, hast du das mal gerade irgendwo?
In der Mail, die ich dir geschickt habe.
In der Mail, das ist einfach der Macintosh, der beim Einschalten des Macs als allererstes aufleuchtet.
Genau, und da drüber steht irgendwie auf einer weißen, auf einer roten Banderole, Censored. Und wenn man da draufklickt, steht da, warum dieser Talk zensiert ist und wo man ihn auf YouTube findet. Und jetzt ist natürlich so, keine Ahnung, man könnte sich jetzt irgendwie, könnte natürlich sagen, dass das eine suboptimale Lösung ist, weil man nicht für die freie Information gekämpft hat. Andererseits finde ich das auch nicht verkehrt, mal in so einer App eben auch zu zeigen, so einfach auf so eine Praxis hinzuweisen. Was mich so ein bisschen unglücklich stimmt, ist eben, dass jetzt die Leute oder dieses Team jetzt irgendwie auf die Reputation des Ccc zurückgreifen und auf die Möglichkeit, öffentliches Interesse für diesen Fall zu generieren. Das wurde ja dann irgendwie auch auf Heise und so behandelt. Aber ich glaube, dass es halt sehr vielen Entwicklern teilweise mal anders geht, die dann nicht vielleicht in ihrer Freizeit ein Hobbyprojekt machen, sondern vielleicht eine App entwickeln mit signifikantem Aufwand und Hoffnung auf finanzielle Entlohnung ihrer Mühen und so. Und das ist halt schon irgendwie eine ungünstige Entwicklung, auf die dieser Fall hinweist. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es jetzt diese schöne App, eben doch im App-Store. Es gibt sie auch auf GitHub. Und wir haben leider noch nicht direkt den finalen... Also ist sie schon released? Also der Peter Schorr hat auf Release gedrückt, aber es dauert dann immer noch so ein bisschen, bis es dann auch wirklich einen Url gibt, wo du darauf verweisen kannst. Aber wenn du jetzt auf deinem Apple TV nach Ccc Tv im Store suchst, dann müsste der Store sagen, kaufst du hier für 0 Euro.
Ist aber nicht gefeatured hier.
Das gibt es ja wohl nicht. Das ist ja eine Frechheit.
Willkür.
Kann man auf jeden Fall gut nachsuchen.
Da ist es, Ccc Tv.
Ich bin der Winkelkatze.
Guck dir das an.
Aus der Technik. Laden. Kostenlos laden, ja, wir laden das jetzt. The Ccc is besides being Europe's largest.
Da müssen wir nochmal ran.
Das ist so klar, dass man hier nicht in dieser Sendung einfach mal sich freuen kann, dass so eine App release wird.
Wir haben uns doch schon gefreut.
Ja, jetzt muss man ja auch. Keiner ist so ungeschoren davon.
Du, als hier dieser Typ ankam, also dieser Typ, sorry, ich hab jetzt dein Nickname vergessen, als man das Bingo präsentiert hat, was Tim als allererstes gemacht hat, war ja auch ein halbstündigen Vortrag darüber zu halten, welche Features jetzt eigentlich noch angebracht werden.
Das müsste sich mittlerweile rumgesprochen haben, wie ich mit solchen Zügen funktioniert habe.
Also Hörer dieser Sendung dürften darauf vorbereitet sein.
Lasst euch nicht darauf ein, irgendwas...
So, jetzt sagen wir mal, wie hieß nochmal der Talk, der verboten war?
Nimm mal zum Beispiel Jailbreak, eine Einführung.
Na, was war das für ein Event? Du sagtest doch...
Letztes Jahr 2014.
2014, Congress.
Hast du nicht gerade gesagt, der Talk war 2014?
Das kann nicht Camp gewesen sein.
Bench hier, Chet, sagt uns doch mal schnell, welchen Talk...
Du bist doch hier der Experte gerade.
Ich meine, das wäre Camp... Ah nee Camp war ja...
Da, hier ist er. Guck mal, da ist er.
Crypto-Hacking, Export-Restrictions. So, da sehen wir einen schönen...
Und das ist natürlich nicht der Macintosh vom Einschalten, sondern das ist der Macintosh von dem, wenn ein Systemfehler aufgedreht ist.
Genau, wenn die Diskette kaputt ist oder so.
Nee, wenn das Ding im Prinzip... Klicken wir drauf. Klick. This content is not available on your Apple Tv. It was redacted by the Apple Review Team. Because content related to jailbreaking or hacking Apple devices is not acceptable in the App Store. You can still watch the content in your browser. Hmm, jetzt gibt es einen Button. Und?
Oh, da stand der Link jetzt nicht, ne?
Na ja, also man kann... Also Apple Tv hat ja keinen Browser. Von daher ist es jetzt kein Wunder, dass jetzt hier kein Browser aufgeht, weil es gibt keinen.
Das ist jetzt das zweite Gerät, was die ohne Browser bauen.
Das zweite?
Müssen die Webseiten jetzt noch Uhr optimiert werden?
Achso, auf der Uhr ist natürlich auch kein Browser. Da wird auch keiner hinkommen. Das finde ich auch vollkommen... Da können wir uns lange drunter halten. Das finde ich sehr konsequent. Wir werden uns doch schon einig werden.
Ja, aber das ist doch schön. Es ist doch schön. Wir sind jetzt auf dieser tollen Plattform, direkt neben Flappy Bird.
Diese tollen gated community, wolltest du auch sagen.
Also theoretisch, wenn man das jetzt mal richtig sexy machen will, dann müsste eigentlich die Media Ccc.de-Seite eine HTTB-Responsecode 451 geben, der auch relativ neu ist. Wenn es detectiert, dass dieser Apple-Tv-Browser da vorbeikommt, dann ist es ein Apple-Gerät und dann bei all den Apple-related Dingern 451 raushauen.
Hast du gehört, Peter, hier so? Ah, er schreibt, Pull-Requests werden gerne angenommen.
Der weiß auch, wie er mit euch umgehen muss hier. Das weiß ich ja schon vorher, deswegen schalte ich gleich den zweiten Gang. Also, wir gratulieren. Ja, alles super, gut durchgehalten. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass man mit denen nicht reden kann.
Und das war übrigens bei dieser Fall natürlich der Hintergrund, warum beim Opening vor dem Video noch so der Mac-Ton kam und ein Äpfelchen in einer Flasche. Das war mein kleiner Gruß, oder unser kleiner Gruß an...
An den Apfel.
Aber in den Blink-Lights-Videos auf Media CCC, die müssen wir nochmal ran.
Was weißt du schon von Blink-Lights?
Echt?
So, auch Scheiße. Sehr schön, meine Damen und Herren.
Ja, aber so hat die lange traurige Geschichte ein fröhliches Ende gefunden.
Na, immerhin sind deine Two Factor Dokens sicher. Da kann ich alles haben.
Gut, dann kann ich mal wieder auf den anderen Beamer umschalten.
Ist auch schön da. Wir sind doch gar nicht in New York.
Details?
Mit der Hardware-Revision 2 wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
Sehr schön hier übrigens auf der Freak Show Bingo-Seite, sieht man immer, was für die letzten geklickten Memes sind, die wir gerade abgeworfen haben. Wir hatten schon Apple-Euphemism.
Bei Games benutzt ihr diese Jelly-Splashy-Logo. Damit hast du echt was angerichtet.
Ich kriege das von vielen Leuten.
So, sind wir durch mit dem Kongress.
Damit sind wir auch durch mit der Sendung. Nein, was?
Wir müssen noch über Star Wars reden.
Oh Gott, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich hab da nur eine Information für Leute. Ist ganz komisch.
Du hast eine Information für Leute, heißt du möchtest jetzt spoilern?
Nee, ich werde komplett spoilerfrei über Star Wars reden, obwohl ich ehrlich gesagt der Meinung bin, dass die Karrenszeit langsam abläuft. Aber ich sehe auch, dass wir jetzt hier keine besondere Star Wars, wie es euch so mit Star Wars geht.
Die ersten drei, die released wurden, super. Die nächsten drei, die released wurden, naja, geht so bis, ach du meine Nase. Und jetzt warte ich, bis es digital auf meinem persönlichen Endgerät verfügbar ist. Und dann gucke ich mir das mal an. Da kann man lange drüber sprechen. Aber prinzipiell bin ich mit, so ähnlich wie Mate, Club Mate, jetzt ist nicht mehr meine Mate, es ist Kino auch nicht mehr Teil meines Unterhaltungskonzepts, so privat.
Ja, du wirst aber wahrscheinlich dann irgendwann noch böse gespoilert werden, weil dann kann man das jetzt nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Das ist okay. Du kannst es auch spoilern, also mir ist das wurscht, weil du kannst jetzt nicht wahrscheinlich zweieinhalb Stunden filmen, obwohl, naja.
Der Film bringt auch keinerlei dramatisch neue Erkenntnisse.
Deswegen ist mir das auch jetzt erst mal wumper. Also erzähl ruhig, also halte ich jetzt nicht künstlich zurück.
Mir geht es jetzt auch erst mal gar nicht so sehr um den Inhalt des siebten Teils. Da haben wir ja im Prinzip auch schon in der letzten Sendung auf dem Congress auch kurz darüber gesprochen, dass 3D-Movies scheiße sind. Ich habe mittlerweile mir das Ding tatsächlich nochmal in 3D angeschaut und habe mich nochmal davon überzeugt, dass es nichts für mich ist. Ich hatte allerdings ein paar interessante Gespräche mit anderen Leuten, die für die 3D-Gucken tatsächlich einen Mehrwert darstellen, aus Gründen, die mir so noch überhaupt nicht klar waren. Interessanterweise sind das fast alles Brillenträger oder Leute, die eh nicht 3D sehen können.
Die finden 3D gut?
Also die Aussage war, das muss jetzt überhaupt nicht übertragbar sein, weil das ist ja bei jedem anders, wenn mal irgendwie im Augenlicht was kaputt ist. Aber die eine Person, die sozusagen nicht 3D wahrnimmt stark an sich, also für die sozusagen die Welt ohnehin rechts zweidimensional rüberkommt, meinte, es sei halt mit dieser Technik tatsächlich dann ein dreidimensionaler Effekt eingetreten, der halt sonst eben wenig bis gar nicht überhaupt vorhanden ist. Da habe ich natürlich dann Verständnis für Begeisterung. Und Brillenträger sind auch, sagen wir mal, so ein bisschen gewohnt, die Welt in eingeschreckten Kästchen zu betrachten. Wir sind ja jetzt hier gerade komplett brillendos. Ich wiederum, also der eine oder andere Sinn bei mir ist schon stark angegriffen. Nur die Augen gehören komischerweise noch nicht dazu. Und ich fühle mich unglaublich belästig von diesem 3D.
Ich höre ihn kannst du gut, aber gut hören kannst du nicht. Ich höre ihn ganz schlecht oder sowas.
Das Problem bei dem 3D ist ja, oder warum das so belästigend ist, wenn du jetzt da so, du sitzt da vor diesem Kinoschirm, und wenn du zu weit vorne sitzt, also dass der Dreh funktioniert ja so, das liefert dir ein Bild fürs rechte und ein Bild fürs linke Auge. Und normalerweise ist in deinem Kopf dieser 3D-Effekt natürlich auch daran gebunden, wie deine Augen fokussieren. Das heißt, wie sie zueinander stehen. Du kannst sowieso, glaube ich, nur auf ein paar Meter wirklich räumlich sehen. Und deine Augen erwarten, dass sie näher fokussieren müssen und auch quasi leicht schielen müssen, um irgendwie drei Objekte so zu sehen. Und jetzt hast du diese riesige Leinwand vor dir, auf der eine Kamera den Fokus führt und Teile für dich scharf stellt oder nicht. Und mal sollst du nach dahinten gucken und mal nach vorne. Deine Augen sollen gleichzeitig aber die ganze Zeit eigentlich den gleichen Fokus haben, nämlich fokussiere bitte auf diese Leinwand. Und das macht das halt irgendwie ziemlich anstrengend, wenn du irgendwie relativ weit vorne sitzt und noch dazu dann deine Augen über diese Leinwand bewegen musst.
Richtig.
Und dann ist das das Erlebnis für ein Arsch.
Ja, und vor allem bei schnellen, horizontalen Bewegungen, da ist es eine Katastrophe. Also bitte, wer diesen Film noch nicht gesehen hat, schaut ihn euch.
Den Film hat ja jeder schon gesehen. Da ist jetzt nichts Neues drin. Also wenn du sagst, du wirst den Film nicht spoilern, dieser Film wurde ja durch alle vorangegangenen mehrfach gespoilert.
Mein Freund, jeder Star Wars Film wiederholt sich innerhalb von Star Wars. So ist Star Wars. Das ist überhaupt nichts Neues, das hättest du schon vorher lesen können. Ringtheorie, sag ich.
Du dachtest, du hast Star Wars verstanden, jetzt erzähl dir das mal.
Und jetzt komm ich überhaupt, warum ich überhaupt drauf gekommen bin. Als das in die Kinos kam. 78, Februar 78, irgendwie muss das so gewesen sein. So alt bin ich. Und bin da rein.
Damals war das schon quasi eine Wiederholung eigentlich.
Nee, damals war das das Gegenteil einer Wiederholung. Damals war das der Beginn des... Also Zukunft, weißt du, wie das ist, wenn man so jung ist, dann hat man ja, dann findet man ja Zukunft richtig geil.
Du weißt, dass es da für einen Bingo-Button gibt, ne?
Das ändert sich ja, ändert sich ja sozusagen, erst wenn man so 30 ist, Douglas Enders ist, hat das mal schön zusammengefasst, so ab 30 ist dann sozusagen gegen die natürliche Ordnung der Dinge und so weiter. Ich will das jetzt nicht wiederholen. Tatsache ist, mir ging es bisher, glaube ich, nur zweimal bei irgendeinem Film so wie da, nämlich bei Star Wars 1, als ich da ins Kino gegangen bin, da kam ich halt raus und alles war anders. Genau, ich hatte das noch mal bei Brasil und dann hatte ich das noch mal bei Matrix. Das waren so die Filme, wo ich sagen würde, danach hat sich einfach die Umwelt anders angefühlt und hat anders gerochen. Du hast einfach das Licht gesehen. Star Wars war einfach so ein Paradigmenwechsel. Weil du einfach diese Gesamtkonstruktion von Geschichten erzählen und dieser Welt, die dort abgebildet wurde und die Tricktechnik, alles kam halt zusammen und genauso war das halt auch bei Matrix. Auch da wurde so ein komplett neues Ding aufgenommen. Da war es dann halt auch noch das Hacker-Ding. Und diese ganze mehrdimensionale Wahrnehmung der Welt und dazu halt auch die Tricktechnik und diese ganze Erscheinung, diese ganze Ästhetik des Films, das war's. So, und dann wissen wir ja alle, was passiert ist. Der zweite, der dritte Teil ist rausgekommen. Das Ding hatte halt irgendwie riesigen Erfolg. Dann passierte ganz lange lang nichts. Und dann meinte George Lucas irgendwann so, jetzt machen wir mal die anderen Teile auch. Wobei das Schlimmste gar nicht mal war, dass die Teile 1, 2, 3 so waren, wie sie waren.
Das waren doch die Teile 3, 4, 5.
Nein.
Ach so, du meinst, ok, du bist jetzt doch schon weiter.
Ich glaube, es hat keinen Sinn, Star Wars anders zu erzählen, als zuerst kamen 4, 5, 6 raus und dann kamen 1, 2, 3 raus. Und 1, 2, 3 für sich genommen war sicherlich für viele Leute eine Enttäuschung auf manchen Ebenen, wenn auch nicht unbedingt für alle. Und über Jar Jar Binks müssen wir nicht reden. Das war aber eigentlich nicht das Schlimme, sondern das, was sich ihm wirklich und was ihm alle auch total übel genommen haben, ist die Tatsache, dass er es ja dann auch noch als notwendig erachtete, die alten Filme auch nochmal zur Re-Releasen. Er hat ja dann sozusagen 456 nochmal digital überarbeitet und dabei halt die Farben geändert, den Schnitt teilweise geändert und das Allerschlimmste, überall noch irgendwelche 3D-Gestalten mit reingerendert, wo vorher vielleicht nichts oder nur wenig Bewegung war, mussten sich dann halt noch irgendwelche komischen Dinosaurier durchs Bild schälen, von links nach rechts. Er hat diese Kultfilme, für die er auch tonnenweise Oscars abgeholt hat, geändert. Und gerade dieser Aspekt mit dem Filmpreisen ist ganz interessant, weil Star Wars wurde nämlich auch aufgenommen in so eine Hall of Fame, der überhaupt einer der wichtigsten Filme ever von Hollywood und überhaupt das geilste vom Geilen. Da gibt es irgendwie so eine spezielle Selektion der Filmakademie und da gehörte Star Wars so zum ersten Badge, also die nehmen da irgendwie 25 Filme pro Jahr auf und gleich im ersten Badge war der halt mit dabei. Und ein Deal dabei ist, aber wenn du da sozusagen aufgenommen wirst, dann musst du eine Original-Digital-Kopie von deinem Film liefern und die dahinter legen, damit die sozusagen, also du wirst sozusagen filmhistorisch akzeptiert und dafür musst du sozusagen auch so eine Kopie hinterlegen. Hat George Lucas nie getan. Oder anders ausgedrückt, es existiert keine High Resolution 16 zu 9 HD, wenn du so willst, Version von 456. Which is grauenhaft. Weil wenn man sich nämlich jetzt die Filme nochmal anschauen will, um sich sozusagen auf sieben einzustimmen, stehst du sozusagen vor der Wahl entweder lausige Kopien von irgendwelchen VHS-Tapes dir anzuschauen. Es gibt noch so einen einzigen Lichtblick, weil es wurde tatsächlich mal eine 16 zu 9 Variante auf Laserdisc veröffentlicht. Und das ist sozusagen eine interessante Quelle. Aber auch Laserdisc hat halt keine HD-Qualität. Das ist ja auch nur so analog am Mumpitz. Wäre alles ganz schlimm, aber Vorhang öffnet sich Incoming Harmy. Und Harmy ist so ein Freak, der liebt Star Wars, weiß alles darüber und findet halt diese ganze Situation, fand er vollkommen unerträglich. Und hat sich irgendwie auf einen Weg begeben. Und was sie jetzt gemacht haben, ist folgendes. Alle HD-Releases von 456 auf Blu-ray und so weiter. Und es gab dann verschiedene Varianten. Haben sie genommen und haben diese Filme erst mal in den alten Colorspace übertragen. Das heißt, sie haben sozusagen diese ganzen Farbänderungen, die irgendwie alles aufgebläht haben und so weiter, komplett zurückgenommen. Aber es geht noch weiter. Sie haben auch alle Effekte entfernt. Sie haben also sozusagen die alten Filme genommen und die wirklich teilweise frame by frame, auch partial frame mäßig überlagert, mit Upscaling und mit Retusche und so weiter. Es gibt jetzt eine HD 27p und demnächst auch 1080p Variante von dem Original Star Wars, der wirklich eins zu eins so ist wie das Original, einschließlich des Tons, der auch vollkommen verhurt wurde. Also auch die haben den Sound auch vollkommen neu gemixed. Die haben die Soundeffekte über die Musik von John Williams gelegt und so weiter. Und diese Version könnt ihr euch im Netz abgreifen. Ich habe es mir runtergeladen, ich habe es mir angeschaut. 20 Gigabyte MKV-Dateien mit allen Soundtracks, allen Übersetzungen, allen 5 zu 1, 7 zu 1, DTS-Varianten. Alles, was jemals irgendwie im Kino gelandet ist und diese Leute irgendwie haben habhaft werden können, ist in diesen Dingern. Und das ganze Projekt heißt The Original Trilogy Despecialized Version. Ich hab ne ganze Reihe von Links für euch.
Und die sind noch nicht längst in Guantanamo?
Was? Na, da gibt's irgendwie wieder mal irgendeine Fair Use. Die bieten das auch nicht an. Also auf den Webseiten stehen nur Hash-Values. Alter Trick. Es ist sozusagen kein Problem, da ranzukommen. Die Bucht ist euer Freund. Ich tu mal hier gleich mal einen Link in, ein ganz wichtiger Link. Das ist hier so ein Doku-Video, was diese ganze Entstehung dieser Film, warte mal, den hab ich jetzt, glaube ich, zweiter Link, bitte schön, der erste, fehlt ein Zeichen. Genau, es gibt also einen Film, der im Wesentlichen all diese ganze Geschichte erzählt, die ich jetzt hier mal eben zusammengefasst habe. Und dann gibt es halt Star Wars, Empire Strikes Back und Return of the Jedi in dieser despecialized Version. Die haben auch Versionsnummern. Das heißt, wenn dann die neue Version rauskommt, weiß man auch, welche das ist. Also ich glaube, die Original ist jetzt irgendwie 2.0 oder 2.5 oder sowas. Und so geht das dann halt irgendwie immer weiter. So, die ich mir halt runtergeladen habe und ich mir vor allem auch angeschaut habe.
Alle 20 Gigabyte.
Also, ich habe da eine Bitrate am Tag gelegt. Alter. Und das war super. Also da merkt man auch wieder, wie gut dieser Film war. Der erste vor allem und der zweite und der dritte. Also lustigerweise war mir der dritte schon wieder fast neu. Also den hatte ich so wenig in Erinnerung, dass da wirklich so ach so ist das geändert und so.
Das wusste ich schon immer. Empire Strikes Back ist also auch der populärste von den dreien. Weil der ein bisschen darker und düsterer und so ist. Und ich habe gehört, dass die neuen Filme, die kommen halt bei der Generation gut an, die die ersten drei gar nicht so mitgeschnitten haben. Und dann ist halt so die jüngeren Kids jetzt sozusagen, weil Anakin, Skywalker da auf dem Spacepod und so, das kommt bei denen irgendwie besser an.
Ja, ich würde sagen, es war nicht alles schlecht in 1, 2, 3.
Als der weg war, als der nicht mehr so eine Rolle gespielt hat.
Es gibt auch Fan-Varianten von Phantom Menace und so ohne Jar Jar Binks. Also die habe ich mir noch nicht geladen, aber es gibt sozusagen Star Wars, komplett Re-Cut von Fans ohne Jar Jar Binks. Wo alle Front-Rolls sind raus. Er ist irgendwo noch im Hintergrund zu sehen, aber wie eine beliebige andere Kreatur.
Ich habe jetzt noch mal kurz eine Zwischenfrage. Wenn du sagst, die drei Filme sind rausgegangen, ist Realität anders? Ich hatte ja schon mal die These wiederholt von einem Freund, dass das moderne Kino Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er erfunden wurde. Also die Sehgewohnheit, die wir jetzt auch immer noch immer weiter treiben. Da gibt es ja auf jeden Fall noch drei Filme, die so zwei, die mir jetzt so mit Future auf jeden Fall in den Kopf kommen, die auch Meilensteine und Gründer ihres Genres sind. Nee, also einer wäre 2001. Wie war der so auf dich? Weil der war ja auch von 1900, der ist ja 1968, da warst du ja noch viel zu klein. 68, okay.
Hatte er nicht echt eine komplett neue Welt?
Aber Alien zum Beispiel, Alien war 1979. Wie hat der dich damals geschockt? Der war ja nicht so richtig so Future-Future, der war ja eher so...
Da könnte ich jetzt auch eine Menge Filme aufzählen, und Pulp Fiction und so weiter, das sind alles großartige, fantastische Filme. Aber Star Wars und Matrix nehme ich da einfach mal heraus.
Das ist eine Frache nur.
Weil danach war irgendwie alles, weiß ich nicht, da hast du irgendwie anders über die Welt nachgedacht. Also ich habe das zumindest damals... Also Star Wars war im Prinzip die Ankunft der Zukunft. Also man hat das Gefühl, da ist so... Das Licht kam von oben und so wollte man Zukunft, ja.
Mit religiösen Fanatikern und...
Mit coolen Druiden, vielleicht gute Lichtschwerter. Also es ist ja, wenn du dir Star Wars den ersten nochmal anschaut, wie viele coole Sachen da drin sind. Also da ist so, das ist so reich irgendwie. Fast jede Szene bringt irgendwas Fantastisches rein. Und so voll, und vor allem lustige Charaktere. Es war ja auch lustig, die anderen Filme, die haben sich ja immer alle so ernst genommen. Star Wars ist ja wirklich zum Brüllen komisch. Das ist mir auch wie jetzt beim zweiten Mal Anschauen noch angeschaut. Ja, der Wookie. Nur sowas. Diese ganzen Kreaturen. Und natürlich dann auch diese Vision einer so mega multirassischen, interglobalen Galaxie, die ja noch nicht mal unsere ist, sondern halt irgendeine ganz woanders. Das hat ja mit uns nichts zu tun. Ist ja noch nicht mal Milky Way. Und irgendwie läuft da aber so ein ähnlicher Blues wie bei uns, aber es ist halt irgendwie die Sacke cool. Also ist der Haus schon geil.
Nur mal, wo wir jetzt gerade schon religiöse Themen touchen, kennst du diese Star Wars The Animated Series mit den ganzen Sidespins davon?
Nein, das hab ich mir alles noch nie angeschaut. Ich hab mir auch diese, da gibt es auch noch mehr. Da gibt es Filme, da gibt es ja auch so Fernsehserien sogar mit Star Wars Kram.
Ja, aber das sind Animated. Aber die sind verhältnismäßig interessant Animated. Also nicht diese japanische Manga-Nummer, so Captain Future-mäßig oder so, sondern ist anders gemacht. Ich hab mir die mal, die gibt es teilweise auch auf Netflix, weil da ist halt, um mal hab ich mir davon ein paar Mal angeguckt. Ich fand's deswegen ganz interessant, weil die mal zwischendurch mal ein paar Lücken füllen oder ein paar Fragen erklären. So Jedi-Ausbildungen, wo kommen eigentlich diese Laser-Schwerter her, bla, und da gibt es so ein paar Folgen, wo die so was mal machen. Also für den, ist natürlich Blasphemie, ist jetzt Animated und la, la, la, aber ist trotzdem, kommt auch aus, von Lucasfilm oder zumindest Starb gesegnet oder so. Fand ich, wie sagt man, ganz interessant. Würde ich jetzt kein großes Geld verinvestieren, aber da das eh bei Netflix rumhängt, kann man sich da mal ein paar Folgen anklicken, wenn man will.
Na, wie das Star Trek-Universum ist ja dieses Star Wars-Universum auch extrem groß. Das hab ich dann irgendwie wieder gemerkt. Wenn du mal in die Wookiepedia schaust, also die Wookiepedia, wie ihr euch schon denken könnt, ist sozusagen die Wikipedia der Star Wars-Welt. Und wenn man da halt so aktuelle Charaktere im neuen Film, die da so zwei Minuten lang zu sehen sind, nachschlägt, da drehst du durch, was da so an Hintergrundinformationen auftauchen irgendwie, was die früher gemacht haben, welchen...
Du meinst, da sorgen sich ziemlich viele Leute ziemlich viel an den Fingern? Oder aus den Fingern?
Nee, ich denke, dass da einfach sehr viel Kontext auch aus den Büchern und aus diesen ganzen Begleitsachen hervorgeht, die ja alle schon mal erwähnt worden sind. Also da wird jetzt im neuen Film irgendwo ein Wort gesagt, das aber durch andere Filme, nicht primär durch die Filme, aber durch die anderen Geschichten, die halt schon erzählt worden sind, im Prinzip schon gesetzt war.
Mit anderen Worten, da sitzt irgendein Drehbuchautor und denkt, ah geil, dann mach ich jetzt mal einen kleinen Snort und dann sitzen da irgendwie ein paar arme Leute, die in so eine Wookiepedia dann da irgendwie ein paar Wendetext schreiben müssen, wie da die Zusammenhänge sind.
Keine Ahnung, aber es gibt ja hier viel. Es gibt hier Videogames, es gibt Comics, es gibt irgendwie alle möglichen Magazins, Role-Playing-Games, das ist ja Spin-Off-Filme.
Tim, klicke mal hier noch kurz auf das Bild, das ist ja so mein Lieblingsnicht. Dieses Bild hat mir schon das Gefühl.
Oder dieses andere Ding mit Yoda, diese Zweigeteilte, wo du so, The Force Awakens, und dann siehst du ihn so auf dem zweiten Bild so, Penn, The Force Needs Five More Minutes.
Also, dieses Bild habe ich irgendwann mal auf super.io gefunden und habe mich irgendwie halb schlapp gelacht. Das war halt auch zu irgendeinem Star Wars Filmrelease. Ist jetzt in den Show Notes, also im Chat habe ich es gepostet.
Du meinst, ich muss es auch in die Show Notes anladen?
Auf jeden Fall muss ich noch zu sagen, diese Wikipedia und so weiter, also bei Star Trek ist das ja auch ziemlich krass halt. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich bin in ein Club gekommen und Prom hat alle Operation Manuals von allen Star Trek-Schiffen und da sind ja dann auch Zeichnungen und alle Antriebe erklären. Das ist ja eben das gerade dann so an Star Trek. Die haben ja dann auch so Teile, sind halt auch so wissenschaftlich belegt. Zum Beispiel die große Kritik an Star Wars, den Nerds, ist natürlich, dass sie ja so billig davon gekommen sind mit dem Hyperspace. Also ja, wir müssen jetzt mal schnell vom einen Ende zum anderen Ende. Dann gibt es jetzt dieses magische Konzept Hyperspace, da sind wir kurz drin und dann sind wir wieder draußen und dann sind wir da. Wo die Star Trek-Leute halt hingehen. Also wie könnte man das jetzt machen? Wir brauchen halt ein bisschen Energie, aber dann kann man sich da schon irgendwie durchwuppen. Und deswegen ist ja für die Nerds Star Trek eigentlich immer geiler. Aber trotzdem hat Star Wars mir auch Spaß gemacht. Ich finde ja beides gut.
Galaxy Far Far Away kann ja auch sein, dass es in einem anderen Universum ist, wo unter Umständen beim Urknall dann der eine oder andere Elementarteilchen sich andersrum gedreht hat und von daher die Dinge ganz anders funktionieren. Also was weiß ich.
Nein, dann gibt es ja da kein Leben.
Man kann sich das alles schönreden, ja.
Naja, auf jeden Fall die Specialized Edition für alle Leute, die mal Lust haben, das Original Star Wars so wie es im Film... Und vor allem, ich muss dazu sagen, nichts ist in diesen überarbeiteten Versionen erforderlich. Also es ist einfach... George Schulkas hat es geschafft, diese Filme zu modifizieren und einfach genau nichts hinzuzufügen, was irgendwie Relevanz hat für diese Geschichte.
Nichts.
Das ist eigentlich das Schlimme daran.
Jetzt hätte ich irgendwie noch einen super geilen Beitrag eigentlich. Ich muss mal schnell den Link suchen. Da war nämlich kürzlich ein Artikel über Pixar und Disney im Speziellen. War der sogar bei Wired oder irgendwie? Und da ging es so darum, wie auch Disney sich ja am Ende von George Lucas quasi das ganze Schaffenswerk gekauft hat. Und irgendwie war so der Tag des Artikels, dass Disney sich sozusagen die gesamte Kindheit ins Portfolio holt. Also von eben Pixar gekauft, Marvel gekauft, Lucasfilm gekauft und da gab es auch so eine spannende These, dass zum Beispiel jetzt in dem neuen Star Wars, dass halt ein weiblicher Protagonistin, also wie auch immer, ist.
Eine Protagonistin.
Eine Protagonistin, genau, so rum. Man ist mal so ganz vorsichtig jetzt.
Ein weiblicher Protagonist, da hast du im Prinzip schon raus.
Ja, eben halt auch aus sozusagen vor allen Dingen Vermarktungsgründen, jetzt wo halt so was wie die Tribute von Panem und so schon bewiesen haben, entgegen der ursprünglichen Hollywood-These, dass irgendwie Female Characters don't sell, gab es ja lange Zeit auch so dieses...
Und Schwarze.
Ja, genau. Ja, und dieser Artikel, der war echt voll cool. Ich muss ihn jetzt mal kurz finden, weil...
Ich glaub, ich hab den auch gesehen, aber ja.
Der war sehr interessant so für dieses Ganze, was sozusagen hinter den Kulissen auch passiert und wie so jetzt eben so ein Franchise, wie so Star Wars dann eben noch immer weiter ausgeschlachtet wird und wie vor allen Dingen jetzt auch JJ. Abrams, der ist ja jetzt mittlerweile, hat ja den Ruf des Film-Recyclers. Der hat ja auch die neuen Star Trek Filme gemacht und die quasi aus der Bedeutungslosigkeit wieder herausgehievt. Also die letzten Star Trek Filme, die konnte man alle nicht gucken und Star Trek war jetzt im Prinzip ja auch tot mit der letzten Serie, die gefloppt ist. Und jetzt macht er das Gleiche mit Star Wars ohne eben, wie er schon gemeint, eine Ringtheorie und das wiederholt sich alles, ohne irgendwas Neues wirklich hinzuzufügen, aber dem Ganzen nochmal so einen Anstrich zu geben, dass die ganzen Die Hard Fans irgendwie sich so wieder zu Hause fühlen und dann eben auch nicht so mit sowas wie Jar Jar Binks konfrontiert werden, aber dann auch gleichzeitig wieder so eine neue Gruppe erschlossen wird. Das war echt...
Da ist was dran. Also der Film bringt richtig geile neue Charaktere an Start. Es ist eine sehr komplexe Übergabe aus dem alten System ins neue System. Und auf den ersten Blick kommt einem sehr viel bekannt vor. Und auf den zweiten Blick merkt man, dass das Absicht ist und keine Nachlässigkeit. Und woran ich sofort gemerkt habe nach kurzer Zeit, dass das hier eigentlich alles in Ordnung ist, ich habe mich bestens amüsiert. Das fand ich einfach sehr unterhaltsam. Und es ging halt auch kein Problem, mit dem Film gleich noch ein zweites Mal anzuschauen. Ich glaube, ich würde mir sogar noch mal angucken.
Der Artikel war im Economist. Es scheint den auch auf der Webseite zu geben, mit so einem Paywall-Schüssel. Vielleicht kann man das befreien. Aber der Artikel war echt ganz cool, wie so oft im Economist. Aber bei Star Trek war das ja das Gleiche. Ich dachte mir so, ey, die machen jetzt ein Film über ein Prequel für Star Trek. Also die alte Enterprise mit Joghurtbecher, Interfaces und so weiter. Wie soll das denn jetzt glaubhaft in HD 21. Jahrhundert transportiert werden? Und dann der Trailer, hatte ich ja auch bestimmt schon ein paar Mal erzählt, sah so aus wie Kirk und Spock, wie Beverly Hills 90210 im Weltall, wo die sich um so eine Frau dann kloppen irgendwie in das Baseball. Und ich dachte mir, oh Gott, was wird das denn jetzt für ein Drama? Und dann bin ich auch diesen Film rein, und dann gehen die das erste Mal auf die Enterprise-Brücke, und dann macht das diese Bling-Bling-Geräusche, und so weiter. Und obwohl das alles modern aussieht, hat man sich als Trekkie sozusagen dann auch sofort zu Hause gefühlt. Und das hat der JJ. Abrams da mit seinen Leuten schon echt erstaunlich gut hinbekommen, so diese Brücke zu schlagen zwischen, na ja, hier die Alten abholen. Und auch die Charaktere waren auch super, also der junge Kirk und Scotty und so, die waren einfach genau, wie man sich das so vorstellt. Und trotzdem halt immer wieder so ein bisschen was Neues dazu. Aber andererseits muss man auch dem JJ. Abrams sagen, so richtig die Meilensteine der Filmgeschichte hat er halt auch noch nie geliefert. Und bei den Serien hier mit Lost, gerade das dramatischste Beispiel, hat er halt immer so dieses Ende von irgendeine übermächtige Macht oder Gott oder was auch immer, um dann irgendwelche komischen Verwicklungen in der Story aufzulösen, die anders weit sich gar nicht mehr zu erklären sind. Das hat jetzt bei Star Wars und Star Trek nicht gemacht. Da bin ich auch echt froh. Aber so bei den ganzen anderen Filmen, die er vorher gemacht hat, war das immer irgendwie so ein Lacklaster-Moment.
Naja, auf jeden Fall hat er jetzt den erfolgreichsten Film aller Teile. Produziert ist ja auch schon mal was. Das muss man auch erstmal hinkriegen, Abatars zu hängen.
Hängt halt auch damit zusammen wahrscheinlich. Oder hat auch durchaus damit zu tun, dass das jetzt halt auch unter Disneys Hand ist. Das ist in diesem Economist-Artikel, da steht auch echt super schön oder aufschlussreich erklärt, wieso bei Disney eigentlich so die Umstellung stattgefunden hat und von diesem totalen, ja auch dem Untergang geweihten Konzern wieder das komplett umgedreht wurde. Steve Jobs hatte auch natürlich eine prominente Rolle.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob 789 die nächste geile Trilogie wird. Nachdem irgendwie Herr der Ringe da mal so fruchtbar abgeräumt hat.
Lenz Flair, Ah, Brahms. Also ich poste mal den Link zu dem Economist-Artikel. Disney making fortune and safeguarding its future by buying the childhood piece by piece. Aber wenn ihr an diesem Paywall-Dings vorbeikommt, schickt mir mal einen Link, wie man das macht. Wo ist denn hier die Workflow-Geschichte?
So, ich muss ja sagen, ich fand diesen, wie heißt der, PB-8 oder was, diesen Druiden, der hat den Film für mich eigentlich rausgerissen. PB-8 ist geil, der ist ganz cool, das wäre echt noch ein Konzept so.
Da gibt es ja diese nette Ding, weil es in letzter Zeit durch unsere Twittersphäre ging, dieser nette Mini-Comic. Oder du siehst den R2-D2 auf dem Death Star. Die beiden so, ja ich bin es, ich weiß, das wird so nichts mit uns, aber wir sollten es nicht tun, weil ich bin ja... We should do this, I mean you're a rebel droid and I'm an imperial Death Star. Oh what the hell, how would anyone ever know, stick it right in my data port. Und dann da drunter das Bild von PB-8. Ist auch wirklich echt der Dach von R2D2 auf dem Death Star.
Das Internet, immer für den Lacherjude.
So, jetzt haben wir auch genug über Star Wars geredet.
Na, ist jetzt auch gleich Mittwoch.
Außer, dass Voldemort auch mitspielt und so. Das sollte man ja nochmal separat beleuchten.
Ja, genau. Ich hab da auch noch was Nettes gefunden. Es gibt ja diese geilen Crawl bei Star Wars. Und hier, methodisch inkorrekt.
Achso, die hatten ja auch so was.
Auf die ich auch nochmal ganz am Ende dieser Sendung kommen werde. Ganz am Ende. Die haben ja auch so einen Star Wars-Crawl gehabt am Anfang ihres Talks. Und ich dachte mir so, warum ist denn das jetzt her? Könnte sein, dass sie den Star Wars Intro Creator benutzt haben, den es natürlich gibt im Netz. Da kann man dann sozusagen seinen eigenen Text irgendwie eingeben, klickt auf Play und dann hat man halt irgendwie exakt dasselbe Opening wie bei Star Wars, wo dann halt irgendwie dieser Text entsprechend durchfliegt.
Mit WebGL oder was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie sie das gemacht haben, aber...
Ja, mit Sound! Da oben, da sehe ich öfter im Browser, sehe ich dort. Mach mal Sound an. Hat Sound.
Volles Programm.
Freak Show oben rein schreiben, Show-Notes reinposten.
Tim, wie kannst du dir sowas empfehlen, wenn das nicht 3D ist? Das ist doch nicht 3D. Das war doch nicht 3D. Du hast das jetzt hier unkommentiert einfach vorgestellt, ohne dich zu beklagen, dass es noch nicht stereoskopisch 3D ist.
Ich bin ja nicht so ein...
Er ist ja anti-3D.
Ich finde ja nicht. Also bisher hat mich das alles noch nicht so überzeugt, mit diesem scheiß 3D zu sein. Mich haben auch Computerspiele noch nicht restlos überzeugt.
In 3D oder grundsätzlich? Grundsätzlich. Computerspiele nicht so dein...
Ja, ein paar schon, aber so an sich.
Lieber Outliner, ne?
Wenn man mal dieselbe Energie in Outliner fließen würde, wie in Games...
Mein Kuchen hat mich mit dem Kopf auf den Tisch aufgeschlagen.
So, jetzt können wir aufhören oder noch über tausend andere Sachen reden, die wir aber auch nächstes Mal behandeln können.
Ich dachte, wir reden über Marte.
Das war doch vorhin schon mit der Marte-Box-Ablösung.
Den Link können wir auf jeden Fall noch mal in den Chat posten.
Ja, da liegt die Sendung schon so lange.
Aber wurde ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dass die Marte...
Ich muss übrigens noch nachträglich sagen, du hast natürlich recht mit dem Frizante, wie die Italiener sagen, also dem Sprudel-Anteil.
Pricke.
Aber ja, ich hab nochmal dann einen Chunk getrunken mit Flora. Ich fand's auch geil, also... Aber ich verstehe den Punkt auf jeden Fall. Es ist schon ein anderes Feeling auf der Zunge.
Bin ich zwischendurch eingeschlafen? Habt ihr da jetzt schon drüber gesprochen?
Nein, wir haben das nur ganz kurz.
Okay, die Marthe-Bach-Ablösung hatten wir a. schon in der letzten Freak Show. klang das auch vorhin kurz an.
Kurz war, dass wir jetzt die Existenz dieses Testvideos...
Die Chathörer, ja, da gibt's halt so ein Testvideo, wurde mir danach gepostet, wo dann irgendwie so ein, von irgendeiner Redaktion, weiß nicht, was, zeit.de oder so?
Z-E-T-T-E.
Oder so, genau, ja.
Das Bento von Zeit Online oder so.
Genau. Haben halt so einen Blindtest gemacht, und dann kam Flora Powerball raus als Gewinner. Die User im Chat, die Hörer, die fordern hier oder wünschen sich, irgendwas zu Flattr zu sagen.
Ja, da kann man noch was zu sagen, ja. Sollen wir noch was zu Flattr sagen?
Also ich kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass meine erste Abbuchung, ich hab jetzt einfach lange gewartet und hab einfach da so die kleinen Euros sich ansammeln lassen, weil ich dachte, okay, mal gucken, bis der Staub sich gelegt hat, mit dem ganzen Bank- und Auszahlungs- und Einzahlungssystemwechsel. Und jetzt hab ich tatsächlich mal geklickt und das ging auch sofort. Also irgend ein Dibar-Konto akzeptiert, nächsten Tag war es da.
Also meinst du, von deinem Konto zu Flattr meinst du jetzt?
Nee, von Flattr, Auszählzahl sozusagen. Und das war auf jeden Fall schon mal cool. Und jetzt haben sie ja irgendwie auch wieder die Einnahmeprognose eingeschaltet, angeblich, hab ich heute gelesen. Ich muss ja sagen, ich find immer noch das Logo total hässlich.
Wollen wir nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, was überhaupt passiert ist? Weil ich glaub, wir haben das noch gar nicht wirklich behandelt gehabt, oder?
Na, wir haben doch schon drüber gesprochen. Wir haben schon über das neue Flattr gesprochen, auf jeden Fall. Und das war halt gerade nach dieser Umstellung, als alles noch so...
Im Eimer war.
Naja, featurearm, sagen wir mal.
Bottom line ist, liebe Flattr Nutzer, Flattr ist jetzt sehr viel einfacher geworden für euch, weil wir können uns jetzt das Geld ohne Gebühren direkt auf unser Bankkonto überweisen lassen. Und dafür habt ihr ein beschisseneres Logo. Ich glaube, das ist doch ungefähr die Änderung.
Und die Leute können halt auch einfacher sozusagen Geld draufschicken.
Genau, es geht jetzt auch per Bank dahin. Was noch nicht geht, ist Dauerauftrag. Was einzig in der Leiden was damit zu tun hat, dass dieses Mango Pay bisher sozusagen pro Überweisung so ein Token-Ding noch braucht. Und das ist halt alles, um Fraud-Prevention zu betreiben.
Quatsch, das ist ja Quatsch. Das wollen wir ja lieber direkt in schnellen, unkomplizierten Geldfluss in die Metaebene um...
Jaja, nicht nur in die Metaebene, sondern...
Um den weiteren Betrieb zu gewährleisten.
Aber ich verstehe auch, dass das ein Problem ist, den einfach die Zahlungswege haben. Und das, was ja der Idealfall wäre in gewisser Hinsicht, also das Schriftverfahren, das hat halt einfach einen Fraud-Anteil von irgendwie 10 bis 20 Prozent. Das ist halt ein richtiges Problem.
Gut, aber es sind halt 10 bis 20 Prozent mehr für dich.
Also ich kann jetzt noch nicht so viel sagen, aber ich habe halt was klingeln gehört. Und will das mal nur so rüberbringen mit, also A, sie kriegen ihre technischen Probleme langsam in den Griff. Es gibt wohl noch Probleme mit der API. Aber man merkt, dass die Webseite sich langsam stabilisiert. Da sind jetzt nicht so viele furchtbare Leute dahinter. Das ist jetzt sozusagen kein riesen Konzern, sondern im Wesentlichen zwei Leute, die da dran arbeiten. Dementsprechend gehen die Dinge halt manchmal eben langsamer, als man sich das wünscht. Und ich habe den Eindruck gewonnen, dass das jetzt noch nicht das Ende vom Lied ist. Also das, was wir jetzt sehen, ist eher der erste Schritt für weitere Änderungen, die aber sozusagen als Basis erstmal erforderlich waren. So richtig viel genaues Wissen tue ich darüber noch nicht. Ich hab nur, also Bäume haben es mir gesprochen. Ja, und sehr viel mehr kann man dazu jetzt eigentlich gerade nicht sagen. Es gibt nach wie vor die Buttons, es gibt nach wie vor die Integration in den Apps, die halt unter diesen API-Problemen ein bisschen leidet. Aber es gibt jetzt halt auch wieder neue Hoffnungen, gerade was Podcast-Clients betrifft. Podcare, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das schon erwähnt hatten, ist ja jetzt auch an den Start gegangen offiziell. Das ist auf dem letzten PodLav-Workshop vorgestellt worden. Das ist so eine Art Syncing-Backend für Podcast-Clients. Und da gibt es jetzt auch schon den zweiten Client, der da mitspielt und zwar Podcast-Addict auf Android. Also es gibt jetzt sozusagen einen iOS- und einen Android-Podcast-Client, die mit Podcare zusammenarbeiten. Und nicht, dass ich mich jetzt gerade was verwechselt habe.
Nein, da ist Autoflatter stand da schon.
Ja, bei dem Client haben die hier keine Client-Lister. Ich komme bei den Android-Klein-Namen immer so ein bisschen durcheinander. Deswegen kann es auch sein, dass ich mich jetzt gerade verplappert habe. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Android-Client, der jetzt mit Podcare zusammenarbeitet. Und sie machen halt auch Autoflatter, genauso wie das das Instacast-Backend gemacht hat. Jetzt haben wir noch nicht so die riesige Auswahl unter Clients. Und keine Ahnung, welche Dynamik das so bewirken wird. Aber zumindest ist da mal wieder was auf dem Tisch.
Was mir halt so ein bisschen jetzt nicht so unbedingt gefällt, also ich meine, einerseits finde ich es total erstaunlich, dieses Flatter-Projekt. Also erstens, dass es immer noch gibt und dass es benutzt wird. Das finde ich auf jeden Fall auch sehr großartig. Und jetzt, ich meine jetzt diese Umstellung ist halt schon so ein bisschen gerade eine Wette, dass auch die Leute, die schon dabei sind, jetzt auch noch diesen Wechsel mitnehmen. Denn wenn man jetzt mal ganz ehrlich und ganz objektiv auf diese Webseite guckt, so richtig nach einem einladenden Service, also wo jetzt auch wirklich, wo man so irgendwie was sehen kann und was klicken kann und gesagt bekommt, wie toll das ist da jetzt mitzumachen. Also das gibt diese jetzige Seite, die halt wirklich monochrom und also da ist nichts so groß zu sehen. Das ist schon, ja, also im Vergleich zu der alten Seite, schon so eine, ja, weiß nicht, so eine Art mutige Aktion, weil ja, ich weiß nicht, ob da jetzt sich wahnsinnig viele Leute gerade jetzt angeregt fühlen, da mitzumachen, aber ja, die, ich finde es halt auf der anderen Seite eben auch schön, dass da immer noch so viele Leute mitmachen. Also man sieht ja jetzt zumindest auf der neuen Seite, wenn man einen Account hat, sieht man jetzt ja auch ein bisschen mehr, wie du ja letztes Mal schon gesagt hast, wo die Flatters herkommen. Das ist ja auf jeden Fall auch schon mal super. Aber man sieht auch jetzt ganz viele Sachen wiederum nicht, die man vorher gesehen hat, die ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen so vermisse. Aber gut, wie gesagt, wenn du sagst, da arbeiten jetzt nur zwei Leute, ist ja alles verständlich, hoffe trotzdem, dass das nicht allzu lange dauert, bis wieder so ein bisschen mehr noch Lebendigkeit und Vividness da so wieder zurück sprudelt.
Ja, das hoffe ich natürlich auch.
Also ich glaube, es gibt ja, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist, steht da ja, Fund, Creativity Support, Free and Open Web, Pay for Free Content.
Ja, das ist immer noch der Spruch, der nicht so...
Aber was mir irgendwie auffällt, sie benutzen offenbar dieses Bootstrap-Framework oder so, weil jetzt irgendwie inzwischen sehen alle Internetseiten so aus und dem wollten sie sich offenbar folgen.
Ja, aber auch mit Twitter-Bootstrap, das ist prinzipiell überhaupt nichts Schlechtes. Das ist so ähnlich wie die Apple Usability Guidelines im Wesentlichen. Also wenn man da sich einmal mit beschäftigt, dann kann man zumindest keine grundsätzlich total schwer hässlichen Seiten bauen.
Genau, dann sehen sie dann halt auch alle gleich aus. Ich finde die Seite schöner. Also du hattest ja einen Punkt, den du hattest, das finde ich sehr einleuchtend, nämlich dass sie den Wiedererkennungswert von ihrem Logo jetzt komplett aufgegeben haben für ein im Prinzip etwas, was aussieht wie dieses Apple-Symbol, wenn die Time Machine läuft oder sowas, kann man nicht ganz unterscheiden. Aber ansonsten fand ich auch schon deren erstes Logo, oder das erste Design, das sie hatten, war jetzt auch nicht der große Wurf.
Ich habe es gewusst, also Entschuldigung, ich korrigiere mich gleich mal, es ist natürlich nicht Podcast-Addict, sondern es ist Podcatcher-Deluxe, der auch dringend mal ein neues Icon braucht, und den ich ansonsten auch nicht benutzt habe.
Und das Fav-Icon ist offenbar noch das alte, oder das ist hier irgendwie in meinem Chrome gecached oder so?
Auf jeden Fall möchte ich an dieser Stelle auch nochmal sagen, vielen Dank für alle Leute, die auch bei Flattr weiterhin am Ball bleiben und diese ganze Podcasterszene und Bloggerszene und so weiterhin unterstützen. Weil, gerade weil das eben so ein Low-Man-Power-Service ist und das irgendwie alles so mit Goodwill und ja, wir wollen supporten ist, dass das immer noch so weiter läuft und auch weiterhin benutzt wird, ganz großes Kino. Also da hat man auch das Gefühl, da haben irgendwie alle Spaß dran.
Wo sieht es aus? Also man kann da eigentlich gar nicht genug Hoffnung dran klammern an irgendwie ein Micropaymentsystem in irgendeiner Form. Also wenn man sich so die, also das hier jetzt auch so steht, support free content, support creators, gerade so in den, oder support the free and open web, ist eigentlich so der Aspekt. Ich meine, inzwischen gehen die Zeitungsverlage hin mit ihren Online-Seiten und publizieren sogar direkt auf Facebook, weil Facebook ihnen sagt, ja, das wäre ja irgendwie schade, wenn eure Inhalte dann irgendwie am Ende gar keiner mehr zu Gesicht bekommt. Und es ist doch auch besser. Es lädt ja viel schneller und wer doch, ich meine, überlegt mal, einen Klick müssten die Leute machen, um zu eurer komischen Seite zu kommen, die ihr da selber unterhaltet. Und so aller Content wird alles in diese zentralen großen Dinger gezogen.
Ab ins Seelo, klar.
Und da gab es diesen, jetzt habe ich den Link, den müsste ich noch mal raussuchen, von diesem iranischen Blogger, der eigentlich irgendwie für ein paar Jahrzehnte eingekerkert werden sollte, aber großzügigerweise nach ein paar Jahren rauskam und dann irgendwie so das Internet wiederfand. Einfach nur ein paar Jahre und das nicht wiedererkannt hat und gefragt hat, was ist irgendwie aus dem freien und offenen Web geworden. Das war schon ein echt eindrücklicher Artikel. Und so komme ich mir häufig auch vor. Du kennst unsere nächtlichen Debatten, ob wir Logbuchnetzpolitik nicht vielleicht doch irgendwann auf YouTube oder sowas machen könnten. Das ist alles so eine traurige Entwicklung, die mich wirklich...
Hat man auch in der Freak Show hier letztes Mal, oder irgendwo schon mal angesprochen, diese Plattformisierung des Webs und so weiter. Ist unaufhaltbar, schreitet voran und von den Usern getrieben.
Ich denke, dass wir sogar im Extremfall demnächst sehen werden, dass einfach Zeitungen darauf verzichten werden, eigene Webseiten zu fahren, weil sie es nicht verstehen, weil sie die Security- und Datenschutzimplications nicht mehr im Griff haben, weil sie es auch nicht schaffen, darüber ihre Leser überhaupt nur nennenswert zu binden. Also das ist alles nur noch so Ad-Fee. Und dann sagen sie, ach, dann lass doch auf Facebook irgendwie die Werbung schalten und wir lassen uns einfach nur die Kohle überweisen, dann müssen wir uns mit diesem ganzen Scheiß nicht rumschlagen, dann brauchen wir auch keine AC-Abteilung und so.
Das ist ja auch total das Bescheuerte eigentlich. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich sehe, dass jetzt Spiegel Online und so halt so 1000, was weiß ich, Ad-Networks hat, die haben irgendwie Deutschlands populärste News-Online-Click-Seite. Wenn die selber ihre Werbung vermarkten würden auf der Webseite, da würden die auch wahrscheinlich, ich meine, Spiegel wird es eh nicht schlecht gehen, würde ich mal vermuten. Aber das ist halt auch so dieses, ja wir haben da jetzt keine Ahnung und wir wollen uns auch gar nicht damit auseinandersetzen, wie das jetzt eigentlich funktionieren könnte mit vielleicht Geld im Internet verdienen, mit Inhalten und so weiter. Ja, die machen alle Werbung, okay, wir nehmen jetzt auch mal so ein Ad-Network oder Paywall machen jetzt alle, alles klar, machen wir jetzt auch. Und da gibt es so viel Potenzial eigentlich auch noch für diese ganzen Zeitungen, Verlage, was auch immer, was zu machen, aber es ist halt irgendwie gar nicht.
Kannst davon ausgehen, dass die auch beteiligt sind.
Ich würde da gegenargumentieren, wenn du überlegst, was es den Spiegelverlag oder kostet, diese eigene Infrastruktur zu unterhalten und überhaupt irgendwelche Verträge noch mit so Ad-Vermarktern zu machen. Und nimmst diese Summe und sagst, ok, wir streichen das alles, publizieren nur noch Featured, Articles oder wie das da heißt, auf Facebook und pumpen das Geld, was wir vorher in diese ganze Infrastruktur gegeben haben, in Facebook, um unsere, um irgendwie sponsored-Dingens da zu machen. Ich fürchte, dass ich denen da... Ich hoffe, die hören diese Sendung nicht, weil...
Die verdienen ja nichts an der Facebook-Werbung.
Na, das wird sich ja mittelfristig in irgendeiner Form ändern.
Also du kannst auf jeden Fall mit Werbung nicht mehr Geld verdienen, als wenn du deine eigene Werbeplätze auf deiner eigenen Plattform verkaufst. Das ist ja genau das Erfolgsrezept von Facebook. Und wenn du dich jetzt hinstellst und sagst so, ja, okay, Google oder Facebook, ihr habt dieses tolle Ad-Network und so, und können wir da nicht auch mitmachen. Du bist ja immer nur am Ende der Nahrungskette. Und wenn du richtig sozusagen abschöpfen willst und du hast schon so eine Content- und User-Base, die einfach massiv ist, dann ist das geilste und beste, was du machen kannst, einfach sagen, pass auf, so jetzt hier Daimler, du willst irgendwie dein Auto mal bewerben, dann gehst du jetzt nicht über 23 Ad-Network, sondern wir verhandeln jetzt mal hier so exklusiv und so weiter. Das machen die ja wahrscheinlich auch bei ihrer Vollflächenwerbung und so weiter, aber sich sozusagen dann irgendwelchen anderen Plattformen auszuliefern und deren AGBs und was nicht noch, das ist einfach...
Natürlich ist das totaler Unsinn.
Und wirtschaftlich kann ich mir auch nicht wirklich vorstellen, dass das Sinn macht, aber gut, wer weiß. Wir sind ja alle nicht im Geschäft, glücklicherweise auch.
Ja, aber das freie und offene Netz, das muss irgendwie am Kacken gehalten werden.
Jetzt wieder die Brücke zurückklammert zu, Flatter ist toll, bitte weitermachen, damit auch die Freak Show in Zukunft Facebook-frei bleibt und nicht auf YouTube veröffentlicht wird und.
Ich habe jetzt für den Schluss noch ein Thema, das kam auch schon im Chat auf und ich hatte das auch schon mal notiert, aber das können wir nicht weglassen, weil es einfach so awesome ist. Falcon 9, die Landung, ich habe zufällig saß ich hier mitten in der Nacht, Tweets rauschten an mir vorbei und ich dachte, das ist jetzt nicht gleich. Klickte dann da irgendwie zufällig in den Livestream rein und war so auf den Punkt, genau in dem Moment, als alle anfingen so richtig zappelig zu werden. Falls irgendjemand noch nicht verstanden hat, worum es geht, also Falcon 9, die Rakete von SpaceX, die ja jetzt schon mehrere Versuche gestartet hat nach einem erfolgreichen Start, den Hauptteil der Rakete, die erste Trägerstufe, selbstständig wieder landen zu lassen. Das haben sie am Anfang versucht auf dieser Wasserplattform, das ist ein bisschen misslungen, nicht wegen der Plattform, sondern wegen anderen Sachen, zu wenig Sprit und alles halt noch nicht so auf den Punkt gemacht. Und jetzt haben sie ja gleich, nachdem ja der vorletzte Start komplett in die Hose gegangen ist, also wo die Rakete ja explodiert ist, haben sie jetzt sozusagen alles auf eine Karte gesetzt, haben irgendwie diesen Start gemacht und dann auch gefühlt so ein paar Meter weiter wieder gelandet.
Es gibt ja diese Langzeitaufnahme, wo du das Licht siehst von dem Triebwerk, wie es wegfliegt und wie es sozusagen fast an der selben Stelle wieder landet. Das ist schon krass.
Das ist auch so ein Elon Musk Ding, ne? Der Junge, ey.
Der Typ, der ist wirklich ein bisschen krass.
Unbekannt, der kann.
Nicht nur, wer hat, der kann. Einen Paypal gründen und schon kannst du irgendwie... Und das Erstaunliche oder das Tolle an dem Teil ist ja dann, dass...
Du kannst den wiederverwenden.
Du kannst den wiederverwenden und hast den Schrot nicht rumfliegen.
Genau, hast den Schrot nicht rumfliegen. Ich meine, die erste Stufe fällt sowieso mal runter. Aber trotzdem, Satelliten hoch, Satelliten runter. Zack, auftanken, hoch, runter. Ist schon okay.
Auch mit Supercharger und kostenlos Spritzen.
Supercharger in der Stratosphäre hält dann an für 20 Minuten. Ja, aber es macht deswegen... Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal... Es ist aus mehreren Gründen spannend. Erst weil es sozusagen... Jetzt ist kein Ton dabei. Genau, da sehen die Hörer jetzt eh nicht. Es ist natürlich aus Technologie-Gründen spannend. Das heißt, du guckst dazu, als Nerd denkst du so geil. Aber es ist auch insgesamt wichtig, weil es damit schafft, Lasten in den Weltraum zu bringen, für immer noch teuer, aber nicht mehr so für ultra-mega-unerschwinglich wie jetzt sonst nichts. Das heißt, erst durch solche Technik wird es möglich sein, künftig mal eben mal ordentliche Raumstationen zu bauen oder andere Sachen zu machen, wo du halt einfach mal ein bisschen Material hochschicken musst. Und das ist sozusagen die langfristige Folge von diesem Projekt. Das kann man natürlich noch mal verfeinern und verbessern, aber sozusagen jetzt mal für nicht total billig, aber für deutlich billiger als sonst mal ein paar Tonnen ins Weltall hochzuschießen, ist schon der geile Impact von der Sache.
Und lässt keinerlei, also wirklich Fully Reusable steht hier. Da fällt kein Stück Schrott irgendwo hin, was dann irgendwo noch unten ist.
Ich denke mal von den oberen Stufen, oder wenn das Ding oben ist, die haben ja diese Kapseln, die das Ding schützen, die den eigentlichen Satelliten schützen, aber trotzdem, das was teuer ist, und das ganze Ding unten, das kannst du sozusagen, das kommt halt wieder runter und stellt sich wieder dahin, wo es vorher war. Tesla-Autopark sozusagen.
Die Trägerstufe, die erste Trägerstufe kostet, glaube ich, neu zu bauen 30 Millionen Dollar, das Teil.
Was auch schon verhältnismäßig billig ist im Vergleich zu den anderen Dingern.
Kannst du einen Garten stellen.
Kann man sagen, aber das ist der teuerste Teil dieser Rakete. Aber immerhin, um so ein paar Tonnen Metall ins All zu kriegen, muss er halt erstmal 50 bis 100 Millionen ausgeben.
Weiß nicht, was so ein Launch-Spiel berechnet wird. Mit was fliegt es?
Das ist jetzt der Punkt. Sie haben ja jetzt auch die zurückgekehrte Stufe untersucht und meinen, die wäre wohl auch ganz okay. Ich meine, das werden wir dann sehen, wenn sie sich auch trauen, das Ding nochmal zu starten. Aber wenn es nur ums Betanken geht, also was da sozusagen an Flüssig-Treibstoff reingeht, das kostet genauso viel wie die Betankung einer Boeing 747. Nämlich 200.000 Dollar. Jetzt kann man sagen, oh, das ist ja jetzt gleich um 29,8 Millionen billiger geworden. Das wäre glaube ich so ein bisschen Milchenrechnung, weil es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass da jetzt keine weiteren Kosten mit verbunden sind, so ein Ding wieder in Betrieb zu nehmen und so weiter.
Du musstest ja erstmal eine Garage fahren und so.
Ja, Checking und personal und hast nicht gesehen, aber es wird sich zeigen, wie die Ersparnisse sind. Ich habe verschiedene Einschätzungen gehört von irgendwie 10 Millionen weniger, 20 Millionen weniger, das muss man mal schauen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein nennenswerter Beitrag. Und wenn es ihnen halt gelingt, so ein Ding zwei oder drei Mal zu re-usen, dann ist es ganz gut. Aber das interessante ist, dass das, was die Falcon 9 an sich billig gemacht hat, durch ihren eigenen Erfolg in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon wieder in Gefährdung gerät, weil sie halt einen hohen Grad an Automatisierung haben. Das liegt vor allem daran, die Falcon 9 ist ja, also was da ja tatsächlich dritt ist in dieser Trägerstufe eins, das sind ja mehrere Raketenmotoren. Und wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, sind das so was wie zwölf oder vierzehn oder so was in der Größenordnung. Genau, also du hast unten halt so mehrere Löcher und das sind halt alles identische Teile.
Wenn da einer von Zug, tauscht man nur den aus.
Ja, genau das ist so der eine Punkt. Aber der Hauptvorteil ist, du musst halt dasselbe Teil der selben Bauart aufbauen und dann lohnt sich eine Automatisierung, wodurch du einerseits die Handverarbeitungskosten senkst und nebenbei dadurch natürlich auch noch eine höhere Fertigungsqualität bekommst, wie das eben so ist mit Automatisierung. Also wird sozusagen doppelt beflügelt. Das heißt, die Falcon 9 ist jetzt auch deshalb so auf dem Weg, sehr wirtschaftlich zu arbeiten grundsätzlich, selbst wenn man alles wieder wegschmeißt, weil sie halt relativ viele von diesen Motoren bauen müssen, die immer wieder gleich sind und da einen hohen Automatisierungsgrad erzielt haben, offenbar. Wenn allerdings jetzt, also Triebwerk gesagt, wenn nicht Motoren, wenn jetzt sie allerdings alle wieder runterkommen und mehrfach verwendet werden können, dann müssen sie auf einmal nicht mehr so viele davon bauen.
Nein, nein, nein, du hast einen Punkt vergessen. Die Idee ist ja, man macht es ja, damit man mehr fliegen kann. Damit man mehr Schrott hochschießen kann. Und wenn du das wieder machst, dann geht die Rechnung wieder auf. Wenn du genauso viel fliegst wie vorher, wie man die letzten 40 Jahre geflogen ist, dann kann man sich überlegen, ja, dann schießt sich das selber an den Fuß. Aber wenn du sozusagen durch die Verbilligung die Menge des Materials, was du da hochdonnerst erhöhst, dann wird wieder häufiger geflogen. Und dann lohnt sich auch die Automatisierung. Kann man natürlich jetzt wieder überlegen, ob das schlau ist, ökologisch oder weiss nicht, mit was fliegt das Zeug? Was ist da der Treibstoff?
Fossil, irgendwas, nein, keine Ahnung.
Muss ja nicht.
Nee, muss nicht.
Kerosin würde ich jetzt erwarten.
Nee, Quatsch, das braucht mehr Energiedichte.
Oder sonst sowas.
Tim, Raumzeitraketenantriebe Nummer drei.
Also Raumgreifenzeit, Schätzer Kerosin, okay.
Falcon 9 fliegt mit Kerosin. Dann möchte ich die doch nicht so häufig fliegen haben.
Diesel.
VW hat da einen schönen...
Na manchmal sind das ja so Festbrennstoffe und manchmal, oder? Gibt es nicht auch so Festbrennstoffe? Nee, gibt es nicht.
Fuel ist LOX RP1.
Eine Ariane hat ja links und rechts diese Booster. Das ist ein relativ schweres Teil. Und die Booster sind halt Feststoffraketen, das heißt, die werden einmal angezündet und dann kriegst du sie nicht mehr aus. Die brennen halt wirklich bis zum bitteren Ende und sind dementsprechend auch problematisch und halt überhaupt nicht recycelbar. Und die Falcon 9 hat halt keine Booster, sondern die macht halt alles irgendwie über normale Düsen, soweit ich da informiert bin.
Das ist eine Refined Form of Kerosin. Aber nochmal ein bisschen geiler, ein bisschen cooler. Und sie findet toller, weil es weniger toxisch ist oder kardiginogen wie Hyrazin und so eine Sachen. Nehmt doch noch ein bisschen Sauerstoff mit, braucht man auch. Weil mit Kerosin da oben doch ein bisschen dünner. Aber nimmt sozusagen flüssigen Sauerstoff mit und die sind RP1.
Könnt ihr mal sehen, weil ich alles weiß.
Toll, Linus, hat sie gut gemacht.
Das Ding hab ich hier auch eingeladen. Wir wollten einfach mal das Niveau heben.
Diese passierenden Tränstoffe, das war verrückt, die Energiedichte. Wenn man da nicht alles mitgewuppt kriegt, schade, dass die leider nicht so...
Das Hydrazin ist halt, wenn ich das nicht wieder verwechsel, das Zeug, was sie mit hochschicken für die dauerhaften Steuerdüsen, weil es den Vorteil hat, dass du es jederzeit problemlos ignited bekommst. Also wenn du sozusagen da so ein Satellit hast, der irgendwie drei Jahre lang irgendwie rumfliegt, dann musst du mal seinen Kurs wechseln, dann kriegst du halt auch zuverlässig diese Düsen gestartet.
Ja, da oben dürftest du auch gerne rumgiften und rumkratzen gehen. Du sollst halt nur nicht in der Atmosphäre damit rumfliegen. Das mag ich nicht so gern.
Ja, aber zu seiner Gewissenserleichterung verkauft der Elon Musk dann noch einen Tesla.
Er soll als erstes mal seine ganze Transportkapazität dazu nutzen, da man aber ordentlich was hoch zu schieben, dass man mal ein bisschen Strom da oben zeugen kann und dann bitte schön normale Ionenantriebe. Ja, das ist oft diese komisch fossilen Brennstoffe und den ganzen Kack. Apropos Ionenantriebe und solche Geschichten. Hattest du nicht Holgi hier beim NSFW oder so? Ihr habt euch darüber unterhalten über den Marsianer? Das war auch hier in der Freak Show. Wo wir gerade bei Filmen und Büchern sind, also Filme habe ich nicht gesehen, aber das Buch fand ich ziemlich gut.
Das Buch war großartig. Das war eines der wenigen Bücher, die ich mir durch den Film dann nicht versauen wollte. Ein großartiges Buch.
Also gerade auch so für Nerds. Weil es ist immer so, weißt du, bei vielen anderen Dingern, jetzt nicht der Klassiker, dass Raumschiffe im Weltraum Krach machen und so, das kennen wir ja nun alle schon, obwohl es Stanley Kubrick echt besser drauf hatte. Aber es gibt halt eben bei den vielen anderen Kultfilmen und so weiter, als ein Jahrmaße als Nerd, der in Physik nicht komplett durchgepennt hat, denkst du jedes Mal so, wie auch dieses andere Comic, was wieder zu Star Wars führt, gibt's da nicht so ein XKCD zu dem Lichtschwert? Wo der neue Jedi-Schüler seinem Master das neue Lichtschwert vorführt, was er gerade gebaut hat und er das ausfährt. Und dann die Frage kommt so, oh geil, where does it end? Und dann kommt der Alarm so, Hallbreach und so. Egal, aber so eine Geschichten, der ist halt einigermaßen stimmig, der Marseaner. Das finde ich halt eben schon ganz cool. Manchmal nervt es ein bisschen, wenn er so jedes einzelne Sauerstoffmolekül in seinem Zelt erzählt und so, aber ich finde es trotzdem mal ganz schön, dass man sich das vorstellen kann, dass das sozusagen hinhaut.
Das ist mal erfrischend für so populär. Also eine neue Ebene Nerd-Literatur, wo dann irgendwie auch noch mal so ein bisschen einer über ein paar Seiten darüber nachdenkt, ob er sich mit den Kartoffeln da am Leben halten kann.
Er macht es ja zugegebenermaßen sehr populärwissenschaftlich, aber trotzdem eben nicht so populär, dass er eben über The Laws of Physics dauernd hinweg springt, wie JJ.
Ja, bitte.
Edo.
Wir lassen es ausklinken und ich sag gleich mal, wir haben da noch ein bisschen geklauten Content, der leider so geil war, dass ich ihn, musste ihn einfach sofort klauen. Wir entschuldigen uns dafür, aber...
Tim entschuldigt sich dafür. Ich hab damit nichts zu tun.
Ohne diesen Bonus Track kann ich diese Sendung einfach nicht beenden. Und ihr werdet dann schon wissen, warum. Ansonsten fahren wir aber erstmal hier klassisches Outro und sagen Tschüss, oder?
Ja, wieder schauen.
bald, das war's, die Freak Show. Wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen wieder.
Verkauf das alte Shirt für die Karten zum Kongress, denn Hamburg plant den Abriss, Erneuerungsprozess. Wir haben es vermisst, es ist viel zu lange her. Der Kongress hat begonnen und alle so yeah!
Komm mit, du brauchst reichlich Koffein.
MI ist zurück und sorgt für Adrenalin. Das VOC filmt und sie fangen an zu streamen. Unterstützt euch's noch, keine Chance, sich zu entziehen. Stockmann hat's gemacht, wir benutzen Ultraschall. Wir laden's frei ins Netz und ihr hört uns überall. Steht's Open Access frei, kommuniziert. Hier zeigen wir euch, wie Wissenschaft funktioniert. Hier bist du eingeloggt mit dem Deck dank dem Pock. Um LAN und VPN kümmert sich das Nock. Hier ist eine Welt, in der fühlst du dich safe. Teebibight an Daten und sie kosten kein Geld. Unten in der Lounge gibt es jeden Abend Schunk. Elektronische Musik und Daten über Funk. Wir zelebrieren die Nacht, haben viel zu wenig Schlaf. Wir holen die Laptops raus, 621 nur bei Bedarf. Flora oder Club, welche Mate darf es sein? Sei egal, welche du wählst, du bist damit nicht allein.